ah hello hello hello hello hi hi hi hi
hi how's it going everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to oxygen
not now today today in specifically
today today there was an update in fact
not even today it was about 30 minutes
ago there was an update to this very
game hi
hello everybody now if you're wondering
why I'm streaming at my normal time when
I be uploading videos is because
something is going very very very wrong
with notifications on my channel I don't
know why but they're not going out so
this is a completely different issue
than the one that everyone always talks
about oh like videos aren't going to sub
boxes or whatever have you this is just
like for some reason and probably a lot
of you guys have noticed notifications
just our believably hit or miss on my
channel right now so I'm gonna hold off
on uploading a normal video and I'm just
gonna stream with you guys because it's
a nice way to hang out and I get to have
fun and I finally think I managed all
the notification things or alerts things
for the various members and stuff like
that so we're gonna play some oxygen not
included we're gonna explore the new
stuff that we have available and as with
most all of these updates I can no
longer play the old save game I mean I
could but at the same time it's not
necessarily gonna be back yeah it's back
it is back baby it is 100% back also
tomorrow I've got a very very special
announcement announcement something
really important that we've been working
on for quite a long time I can't give
you too many details about it until
tomorrow actually comes by but it's
going to be really really
cool so with that being said we're gonna
get started into this game we're just
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna
watch around and we're gonna just like
basically hang out for a good bit and
yeah if you don't know about oxygen not
included it's a great game I've been
playing it for about two years now
there's been constant updates to the
game it's made by the same people that
made don't starve and it's just a fun
way to hang out and have fun with
everybody in chat okay makes sense okay
good Mork
I love okay yes I love this game okay
good alright so I need your help
survival no sweat well only you can
protect your fragile colony from this
harsh and unforgiving universe or the
cosmos is a glorious place where you can
lead your colony into adventure with
ease I don't think that's how we do
things here I don't think that's how we
do things at all I think we do things
with death on the horizon wherever we go
yeah more oxygen not included in dee dee
do in dee dee doo dah yeah what took you
so long with this game I've got other
things on my list and you know there's
there's very few moments when I actually
get an opportunity to just be like I'm
gonna play something that I want to make
or play I want to do this this is real
cool it's really cool
oh thank you so much yeah
so I've got the I've got the alerts set
up to be a little less overbearing I've
got various tiers of it do various
different notification levels and
various different things that you can do
when it comes by so hopefully it'll be a
little bit easier okay so that wasn't
supposed to have what what good luck
mark thank you a thousand Hough
what's a huff that wasn't supposed to
happen that wasn't supposed to happen at
all that that was supposed to happen it
was supposed to be
what's a huff well that's not right it
didn't even take into account the
currency trend oh boy that's that's
gonna be a doozy if that's how that's
gonna be oh boy okay that was not
supposed to happen I don't know what the
Frick that's all about but that was not
supposed to happen I thought I settled
this and I thought
I thought I settled it I thought I got
it better I thought I did the thing but
as usual everything breaks the second I
tried to do anything
relatively calm or understanding and
everything just goes all over the world
and everything just goes to crap the
second that I get into the world there
we go that's what it was supposed to do
there's different tiers so that they're
not annoying they're not horribly
overbearing but thank you all right
and also just trying to gently go
through life without having any sort of
crisis ease make sense
so to summarize something's iffy on my
channel on the notification front
there's a big special announcement
coming tomorrow that you guys are gonna
like it's a project we've been working
on for a long time and I say we because
we've been working on it with someone
that you know and it's just really cool
the announcement tomorrow gonna come out
when things get a little less stressful
so we're just gonna relax unwind and
just have a good old time playing some
cool good game okay this one I'm gonna
keep this one
slow learners okay because apparently
learning was already up so Mary's
staying Marie Lindsay I need uh askin
I'm gonna replace you bottomless stomach
isn't good buff is good but not that
good
germ resistant no no that's pretty good
likes to dig okay Otto you're gonna be
the mole and then airy no Turner yokel I
don't want too many yokels but he's a
real Twinkletoes
Oh Thank You Emily let's see here
Oh dah oh god hang on something just
entirely broken my interface here there
we go just like that baby just like that
you're not a fan of oxygen not included
you're out well screw you then we didn't
need you here we're having a great time
by ourselves like everything's good
hunky-dory here cuz we love oxygen not
included and we are here to have fun
thank you miss frost II love you so much
thank you for helping me through tough
times just by being you and making great
videos well thank you so much all right
so it's good enough now what name shout
out names give me names give me names
for this I need a name I need names for
the new colony the other one was the a/c
happy or the ass happy or her my happy
ass or some kind of hilarious ass some
funny-ass ass fun bot be funny ass the
a/c happy the a/c classy that was it
okay Rudolf poodle doodles I like Buddha
loose the goofy Auto to dilute chika
veil suck really what boob heads I don't
know about that the boner casts
happy-clappy yokel barf these are
terrible some are terrible summer some
are okay say my name well that's a weird
one fatu city turd nugget
nope bubble butt goop axia oh we dying
feud now there's someone who's clever we
dying whew now that's who's who said
that who said that we michael Brassel
now that is what I call clever and
ingenuitive that's what I call clever
ingenuitive and really really cool so
now unavoidable destination no we got it
we got in we dying for you we've got it
all under control
we've got it it's great got it okay so
we got Otto Turner and Mary situation
here is expected resource care deposits
better beats bethbabs beneath the
planet's surface I will sell my
duplicate survive of I investigative of
what's went wrong okay is that me what
is that that's not supposed to be
happening
that nothing has happened that warrants
that why does that happen that's not
supposed to happen this this whatever is
happening here is not supposed to be
happening I have no idea why it's
happening okay so but thank you all so
much for this adventure yeah also I just
want to point out I don't know when the
whole notification thing is gonna be
fixed I sent a message out to YouTube
because of it and I don't know why so
hopefully it gets sorted out soon cuz
otherwise I'm just going to be stuck
until I get some sort of semblance of
support about this the reason I know
it's something bigger is because I
recently had them go into my account and
tweak some stuff because I wasn't able
to integrate anything with discord and I
wasn't in able to integrate anything
with these lights so they went into my
account and they changed something and
now that something's broke so my channel
might just actually be broken and
wouldn't be the first time but I might
have to completely abandon this channel
and start a new one all over again which
would be great
but not unexpected from YouTube so we'll
look forward to that if we have to do
that that would be wonderful
yeah why is this going by so fast I
don't know I've got slow mode on and
it's just is this this is this is
whatever it is okay so we're gonna get
this sorted we got a lot of metal here
we got water down there water down there
light bugs down there alright so also I
I'm gonna do something a little bit
different than I've done before on this
one I'm gonna try to build a little bit
smarter and what's supposed to happen if
that's not supposed to happen I don't
know well I have no idea look look I
don't know why that's I have no idea why
that's all happening there but I got the
alerts set up to be a little less
obstructive and that was like my only
objective in the time being so I'm going
to build out this way
that looks good to me yeah yeah all
right so we dyeing fuse off to a great
start have you planned anything for
Halloween oddly enough no mostly because
we're gonna be traveling out for the
tour in about two weeks now we're gonna
be out and about Bob's actually in town
today we're gonna go get dinner with Bob
and so tomorrow we might hang out and
maybe we can do something then but
hopefully if I get all the problems
sorted out I'll be able to do that but
for Halloween we're not actually gonna
be in town during Halloween so I wasn't
able to plan anything like spook
alysha's I do want to do more spooky
whoa hey buddy how are you doing welcome
to the party yeah I do want to do more
spooky licious stuff but I just haven't
had the time for it am i dressing up as
anything ah well Amy's really big into
dressing up for Halloween Amy's had
these great costume ideas for years but
we've just for some reason for the past
like few years we've never had the
ability to oh boy no no no no okay
you're fine we haven't had the ability
to actually do anything about Halloween
so it ends up that we just kind of like
keep saying that we're gonna do
something for Halloween and then we
never end up doing it but we do have
like she has a ton of ideas that we
would love to but we just won't be in
town for it unfortunately it's spooked
Oh BRR it is indeed it is October thank
you so much you never watch this what's
going on my god let me introduce you to
the Wonder that is oxygen not included
this incredible game filled with
incredible things tons of stuff that you
can do I'm gonna try to pause minimally
here
to buy just like so many different
things that you can do all the time it's
base building at its finest
you guys haven't every time with this
[ __ ] you guys do something that's
just so dumb
why are you going to get that down there
that doesn't make any sense okay
whatever it doesn't matter so what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna start the process
by which we can actually spread out and
I'm gonna have a great big a big beefy
column a big beefy honkin column okay if
you could not seal yourself down in the
death that would be great and then I'm
gonna have a ton of stuff that I'm gonna
be able to do smartly and not dumbly
because I have a bad habit of doing
things dumb in this game and I want to
change that up and do things a little
bit smartly you know what I mean yeah
you know all right so we need to get
this on the way there you're gonna name
your first duplicate mark and then watch
him die that's that's morbid that's a
little morbid I should play Morphin affe
I I did another video just yesterday
where I did three five nights at
Freddy's fan games and I was gonna add
that up and put it up today but then
again the problem with for some reason
notifications on my channel is just
completely bubkis at the moment
yo I'm playing half-life 1 yo thank you
yeah I will be playing Morphin a fan
games very soon but you know they only
come out so often and the good ones are
few and far between at this point but
the ones I got in the video for tomorrow
well two of them are great one of them
is just oh actually that's probably not
coming out tomorrow I got the big
announcement video that we got going on
is coming out tomorrow so be on the
lookout for that big announcement
because it's something that we've been
working on for a long long long time
who's that standing near the light ah
spot twin brother you know the the
opposite version of me some dark version
of me I don't know he's just weird he's
Moody
that guy whatever his name is hey I
don't know if I'm supposed to see the
toilet paper there the paper here I
could probably go get this looks like I
need to actually have three duplicates
on that huh
well I've never had one of these be so
close to that so I should probably go
get it
considering I'm real close I mean I
don't even have to go through this thing
I can't I just dig through this I mean
it's obsidian but I should be able to
dig through this right no no oh
interesting interesting okay we're gonna
go try to get that let's make this a top
priority
cuz I don't want this battery to run out
if I if that's like a time limit to get
it once you see it yeah I'm not gonna
notice you and don't call me daddy what
in the world is wrong with you there can
that be dead like the dab can can we
just admit that that's just creepy on
every possible level that there's
nothing interesting good in any way
about calling anybody daddy can we just
agree as a society that that's probably
a bad idea
that's just like it's just like just
overall Oh God
you had to reset your Google password
just to keep this enjoy it well thank
you for that but let's just agree as a
society can we all just I'll get a poll
going like straw poll we're gonna get a
nice straw poll going well this is like
can we kill the daddy thing yes yes no
papa
[Laughter]
all right I got the pole I think this
one's gonna be somewhat skewed but uh
[Laughter]
stop being creepy guys guys stop it stop
being creepy don't do it don't do it no
don't do it no don't do it no don't do
it don't be creepy don't do it no no
don't do it
open your mouth no don't throw it don't
be creepy I told you don't be creepy
what did I just tell you don't be creepy
oh god it's gonna run out of batteries
no no please please we need it why is
there so much sand in the way no please
please I'm so desperate I just want it
so bad why are you up there when we need
to be down here quite obviously dude no
please please please can i assassinate
your alter-ego starting with dark
applier go for it I guess if you can or
want to yeah but I mean I guess I'm not
stopping you where is the pole here I'll
post it again what do we got whoops
there we go let's see what the pole is
there we go all right
it's very conflicted it's at 57 at 43%
but I think it's just because nobody has
any idea of what they're actually
bumping look at the options I made I
made the options yes Daddy and no pop so
I don't think I'm I think I'm
contributing to the problem if anything
but let's just say that the whole daddy
thing is probably dead okay quick Murray
you go wait let's assign you to Murray
go for it all right Murray
[Laughter]
well that ain't good
Oh y'all right there Murray oh it's hot
it's hot in your brain your brains
cooking um that's probably fine
everybody don't worry about that that's
that's okay that's that's perfectly
normal and what did I just do okay we
okay thank you glad we didn't do that
okay so we need to I'm gonna get rid of
this this and this how how long does
this take
[Music]
is this a countdown of how long it takes
her this is countdown until she's dead
[Music]
Emory where's the pole to plug goddamnit
I keep trying to post the pole why is
that that's not supposed to be happening
why is that happening
why why would that why is that the thing
that's not supposed to be a thing I
swear to god it's not supposed to be a
thing also also raise your hand in chat
if you got a notification of in a stream
or if you just stumbled across it
because I'm I'm trying to get youtube to
help me out here because also for
remember only stuff in the community
post I know you guys haven't get any
notifications for that so I think
there's just something greatly broken
just like Marie's brain after what's
going on also why the hell is this just
this is a big parade here yeah whatever
it's all good okay so what we need to do
is we need to very stupidly and I mean
very stupidly drain the swamp is what I
call draining the swamp yeah we're gonna
drain the swamp down into this thing
even though it's not enough space for
that but I'm just gonna plow it down
regrets come later I don't need to do
that your laptop is wheezing you were
notified notification not notified not
notified
yeah not notified stumbled across it
yeah it's for some reason it's just
super super wrong right now and I don't
know why oh well they'll sort it out or
I'll have to start a new channel but
that's nothing new to me in fact I'd
probably be okay with that let's just
burn it all down and leave it all behind
somewhere else hey guys first stream
what's up
snow man killer welcome to the first
stream no notified stumbled upon it
stumbled across then stumbled across the
notification that that makes sense not
notified stumbled across it yeah it
makes sense didn't get the notification
I don't know like with the whole YouTube
crash - like there's a lot of pages
right now in YouTube that just aren't
working for me for some reason and three
Jesus can you get out of there please
and so I don't know what the deal is
okay now that that's supposed to happen
that's supposed to happen and as soon as
the notification comes with that that
you'll see why cuz I've added little
voice lines in because they think I'm
clever
oh wait oh oh I could have just done
that there it is there it is
thank you John GG sorry I'm at work I
wish I could watch this well that didn't
what the why are you giving stuff to me
yeah whatever yeah Wow so fun yeah so
fun go on the brain scooter how do you
recharge it a waiting duplicate delivery
no wait what what what wait are you
gonna suck something out of another
duplicate just to put into another dude
cuz that's horrible
that's horrible that sounds horrible
you're gonna recharge it by sucking in
another oh my god please tell me that's
what that meant and not just like
something where it's just like oh we got
to deliver a brain to this thing's like
nono ggd notice you I did Dowlen yeah
how do you donate don't work don't even
worry about it don't even worry about it
don't worry about it it's not good we're
just here to hang out we're here to have
fun that's all we're doing
that's all the reason that we're here
there's a shine bug trapped in there so
don't even worry about it it's all good
like thank you for your consideration
but at the same time not necessary in
any way shape or form make a sense good
don't notice me papa now there is
something that I can get behind if we
can start calling everybody papa
I think that's something that we can
actually agree with calling people daddy
is is weird and creepy but call them
people Papa that's like a symbol of
respect right that's like just something
baling hay Papa I love doing
pecans I'm here daddy how you doing
how you doing no no kre actually I like
it less for some reason papa is even
worse how is Papa worse than daddy how
in the world is Papa worse than daddy
Papa what about pop pop hey what about
pop pop some pups there you go that's
pretty good the father somehow that's
even creepier somehow that's absolutely
creepier some
that is 100% creeper oh god my lights
Hey
father father police it's a brother
brother please I need your assistance
brother oh god like man these lights
really like the blink long pops is worse
than both how is pops worse than daddy
oh I did it
did YouTube send any notifications on
the server failure cause nah I haven't
heard anything about it but there's
something seriously wrong going on the
back end of YouTube Thank You Sark jeez
Thank You Sark Jesus no need for that no
need no need at all I appreciate it big
priest is all around
give a big preach to Sark to 3/7 up
there saw father saw so father no no
father is worse than all of them because
the implications are just wrong that
says something is very very
fundamentally going weird in your own
brain uncle sounds better to be honest I
mean even a lot of cultures like uncle
is what they say I guess but at the same
time I don't know if I'm comfortable
with any of these I'm just providing a
bunch of alternatives in the hope that
you guys get confused and you don't know
which one you're gonna use so you use
none of them incidentally but that's
just a weird hope that I have and I
don't think it's ever gonna come true
all right so let's start building a base
here right
and right now I built that letter to
close well I'm a douche and I'm stupid
but then what else is new
okay nope all right there there okay
take that out if we can which we can't
there we go
that's not what I wanted at all is it
no that's not what I wanted I want this
for some reason I feel like this is good
it's probably not but I feel like it is
father plier okay I've started mommy I
think we can all agree mommies worth do
Nancy a call hey Mark thanks for
everything my husband's military so he's
gone a lot i hears your videos to laugh
and not feel so lonely love you
well thank you so much and I'm sorry to
hear that you can't be around your
husband enough but your husband's doing
a great job out there oh oh boy I've
done goofed aah mmm well I seem to have
done goofed real hard ok so what I'm
gonna do why is that blinking
Sark Sark again uh mark can't wait to
see you in November in Brisbane
Australia you have saved my life on
countless occurrences and I thank you
for that by the way love oxygen not
included and please play more SCP well
thank you so much for that really thank
you everybody give a big priest - Sark -
37 over there big preaches all around
big big big preaches do I have the
preachy mode over here because if I
don't no no no no we can all agree ok
the ranking the hierarchy is ok hang on
listen we got to get another straw poll
here we have to this is important this
is fundamentally important for the
culture of the Internet we got to create
a worthwhile environment ok ok which
one's worse we got daddy we got papa we
got pop pops we got uncle we got mommy
for some reason and then we got father
not farther father okay all right so I'm
creating this poll now this one's
important if there's anything that's
going to decide the fate of the internet
it's the
pull right here so you got a vote
carefully on this one
you got a vote real careful yeah think
about it you got to understand it you
got to understand the implications of
what you are implying because you are
dictating the culture of the internet
for the rest of eternity with this poll
right here papa is worse because it's
cute in some way or you want pop I'm
asking which one's worse all right
that's worse have you ever thought of
being a blacksmith rather than an
engineer I don't think about being an
engineer I could have been an engineer
that's what I think about I mean I don't
think about it at all don't even bring
it up with me cuz it's not what I think
about listen listen I had I didn't ask
which one was worse I asked which one
was worst worse suta worst where's the
pole it's in chat I'm linking it look
for my name my name is the one with
yellow around it and a big check mark by
it that's how you know it's me it also
gets stuck to the top so that you got
that there where are the poles there in
chat rookie gamer 4 5 6 open your eyes I
can't make it any easier for you I'm
literally posting in chat you know that
place where you're typing that's where I
am it's right there in chat I'm posting
it it's going by and you can't not miss
it it's literally right where you're
looking how can you not it's the common
it gets stuck to the top of the chat
it's right there there's nothing that it
could be any more obvious so bearnaise
alright let's see what the results of
this is it's in I can't I can't I can't
make it any easier for you also I'm
really excited cuz I bought a new
monitor and it's a it's ok this beast of
a monitor ok we'll get through the
results in just a sec but this beast of
a monitor
it's 49 inches diagonal and it's a it's
it's it's it's a super ultra wide
monitor
I used to have a three monitor setup but
it was so cumbersome it took so much
desk space because I had this big stand
and it was a big wraparound but there's
just one monitor 49 inches hell yeah
big length why have I not got this going
big length we are drowning but that's
okay cuz I got a big monitor and that is
all that I care about ah
we need a new duplicate all right so we
need oh I like that I like that okay
Gausman you're in here
alright Gossman you're you're down to
clown right okay good okay that is some
droopy water and this water is
exceptionally pean like oh the results
of the poll that was in chat did anybody
miss it post a oh one more time all
right there we go
coming in at 39% the worst one as voted
by you and now dictated across the
entirety of the Internet is daddy we've
all agreed on that one coming up in a
very close second place
ernõ second and third place are
exceptionally close down to ten votes in
between them we've got daddy father
mommy
pop-pop's uncle and then way down low
papa
so like I said Papa is obviously the
quote-unquote best of the worst you know
what I mean it's not good all around but
at least this one has some semblance of
normalcy to it you know what I mean it
was like it's not good idea but you know
at least we have something okay I'm
gonna do oh no wait wait we'll [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh Sh
wait no that that can't taint the water
supply that's fine that's bad oh sink oh
that's bad oh that's bad Thank You
Ashley Burrell hey Marky mu I really
love your videos and boob chicas knows
for me more chica more how about
or Henry give everybody give it up for
Henry Henry is just the goddamn sweetest
okay I forgot to put a sink in here cuz
I'm an idiot
sink there we're gonna put two of these
bad boys right I'm gonna put two of
these bad boys right there we're gonna
close this off into a some kind of a
bathroom type device bathroom yep this
is looking good I am really paying
attention to what I need to do door and
tile okay you'll sleep by the toilet
that's good for you that's your choice
all right cool all right beds we need to
build beds yeah Henry do they like Henry
Henry is just the goddamn sweetest can
we all agree that Henry is just so
unbelievably sweet Henry is just a
goddamn delight and whoever like Henry
is the best from start to finish there's
nothing better than him around it oh my
god I'm so happy right now
Colony requires med beds who's sick who
got sick who got sick who who in the
hell got sick weak just alright listen
hypothermia hypothermia hypothermia all
right listen just cuz we're off to a bad
start but we're off to a bad start um I
didn't mean for this to be this bad but
if we are off to a bad start
okay so what am I do I'm gonna make a
bad Bay down mmm okay we're gonna make
the Med Bay
we're gonna make the medbay right down
below because what I want to do is I
want to have a better situation for all
this building stuff and I've learned
some stuff
you called your toilets bad boys come on
Marc that's toilet abuse you are funny
you are funny but I'm the comedian here
so you back off of my territory
all right SCP secret laboratory yes I do
want to play that at some point stop my
breathing with your manly hands papa I
think we found the worst comment on the
Internet I just want to stop everybody
right now because I'm pretty sure that
statement alone takes the crown for
absolute worst thing ever set on the
Internet and that's including like all
of 4chan Thank You Samuel sword been a
fan since 5,000 subscribers I just want
to say you're doing great press B to
blow daddy nope no okay I just said that
we found the worst thing ever said on
the Internet
we've just got a new winner press B to
blow daddy that is the worst thing ever
said on the internet I can fact think we
can all agree all right I need to make a
new straw all right a new straw poll new
straw poll time because this is just
getting bad all right which was worse
which was worse
stop my breathing with your manly hands
daddy or press B press B to blow daddy
yeah okay both of those were probably a
big contender for the worst things ever
said in the history of the Internet and
I I just have to ok polls going in chat
remember if you haven't heard me
screaming about it before the polls are
in the chat they get slapped up to the
top there like a slap chop so you guys
pick which one of those was worse
because both of those are terrible
things that should have never been
uttered by human lips and yet here we
are and you know I just hope and hope I
hope that humanity can be forgiven for
this horrible occurrence that has
happened all right poll is it poll is in
check where's the poets in check I'm
typing it in my big
long name with a big yellow checkmark
you cannot miss it it is so basic I
can't stop you my chat is just an unruly
nightmare uh-uh you don't said I can't
help you if you can't see it where is it
on mobile okay
you have the same chat on mobile that
you do on desktop it's the same
talkie-talkie if you can't type it I
can't help you but whatever do you I'm
gonna start banning people that ask
where the poll is because I can't make
this any easier for you guys how about
now how about now how about now how
about now oh how about now do you know
where the poll is oh I don't know
where's the pole look at the poll B oh I
don't know maybe everywhere
maybe there's Nepal ah where are you
doing okay whatever
dare you got it you sassy pieces of
garbage all right well what are the
results which ones worse yeah that's
what I saw it that's what I thought okay
coming in at 62% the far worse one is
stop my breathing with your manly hands
daddy I think we've reached a new low in
all of humanity and I think we can all
agree that this is just this doesn't
need to exist in any way shape or form
whatsoever so I'm just very upset with
all of you and I think that we should
all be upset with ourselves I think I've
created a problem here because I don't
think someone's sick I got some
mysticism 800 this is just gone to [ __ ]
because I haven't been paying attention
and that's the only reason that has gone
to [ __ ] no other reason besides that
everything would have been fine if I'd
have been paying attention enough and
distracted by all the talk of the daddy
and the such as like that let's put that
right there oh well [ __ ] can't build
there why did I do this
whatever that's gonna be that this is
great this is great
nope this is great boy everybody stop
trying to top themselves with the worst
thing ever set on the internet let's
just agree that the worst thing has been
said and let's not try to beat it
that is like both the most admirable
thing about humanity and also that's
horrible
you don't need what is what is causing
this noise you you what do you have we
out of oxygen ah tits I everybody hold
on I'm really screwing it up and it's
your fault not mine cuz you are
distracting me from the glorious job
that I need to do now and you all are
just hang on it's okay everything is
fine or fine everything is great we're
fine we're gonna put this right here so
that whoever is sick it's all the oxygen
they need they're gonna be oh they're
gonna just chock-full Oh
- there's got to be blasted it's like a
dehumidifier up their own eyes just like
slamming inside of their eyes just like
BAM I feel so clean all right can we
build this please about whatever they're
good they're they're fine probably
anyway and if they're not fine then I
don't care you love me thank you thank
you so much you're in school well why
are you watching this while you're in
school man yeah you're watching anyone
that's missing out on this particular
stream is this gonna be so regretful
because this is a stream where I
announce not only do we have a big
announcement tomorrow but my channel
might be done my channel might have to
be deleted and started over again and
then what the hell are we gonna do if
that happens huh what are we gonna do I
did that five years ago and then I don't
want to do it again but I might have to
because something in my channel is
fundamentally broken and notifications
are going out Thank You Brandon Fox but
love your videos the first stream
welcome I'm glad that this was your
first stream YouTube crashed two days
ago everything's in hell no one knows
where the pole is the chat is gone slow
mode doesn't work and everybody thinks
father's worse than Papa what kind of
world do we live in ah okay
if there was a built-in YouTube poll I
think there is isn't there a built-in
YouTube poll function but I can't be
bothered with that stuff that actually
takes brainpower to think about and I
don't have either of those things
I've got no brain power I've got no
willpower I've got nothing all right
Turner you got this you're about to
crack this but to crack the code yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh there we go all right
so we got to crack this code too but
someone's gotta get down there boy howdy
we have not been able to Bruce any
oxygen or create any of this looks that
directional in that way thank you for so
much of what you do oh thank you so much
you saw your show last in Pittsburgh
it's really cool game called effect that
I think you might enjoy well thank you
so much for that I'll look into it
yeah your live stream is the best let's
let's let's slow the roll on calling
some live stream the best or not because
this is not this is not no no no this is
a great stream no no no you're just
joining now you are joining probably the
bottom of the barrel stream that has
ever existed I don't know why that's
happening that's just been flickering at
random intervals I think there's someone
over at YouTube that's just pushing a
button it's missing because that's the
only explanation for why that's going
off because there's no reason for it
here so I don't know no idea
Stefan Stefan ah oh
what happened what happened Oh evening
from Norway nice to meet you marquel
nice to meet you too
thank you so much have we cracked the
code yet can we please Marie come on
what did Marie get Marie must have
gotten something right I also gotten a
new skill it's not trade right o
regenerative all that duplicate can't
die Oh probably can I shouldn't put it
to the test but I might yeah you are
being the funny guy and being honest I
like that about you okay thank you but
also at the same time I'm not being
funny I'm just screaming a lot and
there's a big difference there's a big
difference between screaming oh ha also
it's burning hot in this room it's never
hot in this room I gotta turn the a/c
down it's hot I'm hot hang on hold on
get ready for slaps all around i-i'll
make I'll get my mods to just go
slapping around with them with the
banhammer I ain't afraid of that I ain't
afraid of you you think I'm afraid of
you the answer is absolutely not
Thank You Kendall Bates you'll keep me
going when I'm in the Navy well
congratulations and hope you do well in
the Navy thank you so much for that is
it that hot I'm not reading the rest of
that you can't make me read these things
just cuz I want to read more and just
because I want to interact with you guys
more doesn't mean I'm forced to read
everything that you say no daddy plier
is not dishing out the spankings no
don't spread that rumor about me that's
not something that I need said about me
where is the pole at big papa okay I am
okay with big papa because I even have
the people that work for me and work
with me call me Big Poppa Pump that's a
private story you don't need to know why
that is but we all whenever we go out to
dinner at the end of the dinner we hold
hands and we praise Big Poppa Pump
everybody if you ask anybody that's ever
interacted with me in any way shape or
form at the end of every dinner it's a
big ol thank you big papa pump and I'm
Big Poppa Pump but we look up when we
say when we say thank you to Big Poppa
Pump well that's me we're all thanking
me that's a true story
not Big Poppa pimp Big Poppa Pump Big
Poppa Pump is the one that we're all
thinking why are you down here guys
guys do you want to do something about
this Association do something why is
that flashing why god dammit yeah thank
you to destiny Crowe back hit the man
Paula Paula Vidor gaming darby rue de
crazy train joe bot Wyatt fire Kaitlyn
Wien Miss gamer Kat Joe Joslyn net Paul
Kiwi Rennicks gaming thank you so much
no I'm not gonna read that Rennicks
gaming no I you I don't have to do that
I'm not gonna read that I'm not gonna
read that no I'm not going it will you
ever go on tour in Indiana we went to
tour on Indiana we did two shows in
Indianapolis you guys you missed out I'm
sorry it's just the way the world works
sometimes okay we need a research
station here cuz why not let's just dig
into here okay why are they not digging
Oh cuz they can't reach it that's right
okay can we build a fire pole yet what
do we need to get the technology for a
fire pole I have no idea
something something interesting
something about that no spank applier is
definitely not a thing either how's your
posture the other day mark it was bad oh
no no thank you CL sec why hope you have
lots of fun on your tour mark and for
slack Kinnison since I'm in Taiwan but
hopefully one day glad I finally caught
a live stream especially of oestrogen
not included well I'm glad you're here
too ah the water it is fallen okay
that's good these these bugs are gonna
get drowned it sucks for them so bad
let's break the let's break the seal
here really seal their fate here they
are they are dry they are very dead okay
so this this this [ __ ] of a base is
up-and-coming but it's you know we're
making do we're making do cuz that's how
we do okay so research there's good
basic farming going okay aha
bring them on we don't even need to
think about not doing anything like that
okay we got you divers lungs love it
already you come in here who's your name
is Bette you in his bit you snuck by me
don't think I'm Big Poppa Pump applier
no we don't need to call it Big Poppa
Pump liar I'm already Big Poppa Pump
that is the only approved name that you
can call me in public in private you can
call me Big Poppa Pump I will respond to
that any other vernacular is not
something that I'm gonna respond to it
must be Big Poppa Pump in that order nan
markiplier not mark not mark EMU Big
Poppa Pump put that on my tombstone what
the hell is going
on Amanda I'm happy to see you plays
again a little pissed I didn't get a
notification that you were live until
now that's the other problem
yeah like live live notifications
notifications in general are just
completely broken right now I have no
idea why I don't even think it matters
if you ring the bell or not at this
point because YouTube has just been
going through some like crazy broken
stuff and I don't know why but frankly
it's okay we'll get through it together
if this channel has to go kaboom it'll
go kaboom and then we'll just deal with
it when it comes but for now we'll just
live and it'll be fine probably if it's
not fine then it's not fine if we have
to cancel this channel and then start
anyone hey we'll do that I'm used to it
at this point okay there we go alright
this can go away now
this can be Doug just to give my guys
something to do how much food we got not
enough okay good good thing we're
researching farming right had a
notification every week of you I think
it only works on mobile it's very
hit-or-miss it's super spotty right now
yeah YouTube is at its teenage years I
mean technically it's rebelling I'm just
mad that I never get a community Tabler
that's what I don't get either cuz for a
while there everything was working
perfectly
and then YouTube does something else and
everything goes to [ __ ] now don't get me
wrong I love YouTube
I'm very little to complain about it
when it actually affects like the basic
functions of the website that are
supposed to work from the very GetGo
that's what I get pissed cuz like it was
working what do you do do you think that
the basic functions of what this thing's
got going on here to hear you think that
worked Thank You Dylan you'd think that
would just work out fine but apparently
ain't gonna work you never got a
community to have notifications exactly
exactly
weeds is very rare it's so spotty I just
I understand the concept okay I'll let
you on a little secret about this the
whole YouTube thing they don't have
everything go out as a notification all
the time because their long-term goal is
to make sure that people don't just
abandon notifications altogether because
it's very easy on their phone just to
turn off all notifications for YouTube
if it gets
too much so they want they want to do is
they want to be very selective about
what is a notification of what's not a
notification that is why things don't
always go out to everybody who is using
YouTube that is why but at the same time
if they just completely remove any
similar to notifications even after
they've rung the Bell then things start
to break down and there's no even point
to even having it in the first place
preventive measures can only go so far
if people actually want it I get the
fact that like they want people to ring
the bell because like they want they
definitely want to be known of God like
notified for this particular channel but
it's at the same time it's just like
isn't that why they subscribed in the
first place
I just me like that's fine I get it I if
they subscribed I figured they'd want to
know about things but that's fine I get
it don't overwhelm people only the
people that really really do want to be
that but people don't know these things
people don't know these things this is
like me saying this to you guys is
probably one of the few times you
actually know like this is how this
works and this is how YouTube thinks
about it like these are these are things
about YouTube that they don't tell
anybody because they're like oh to keep
things on the wrapper and people are
gonna gamify the system and it's like
yeah I guess but also doesn't the
consumer suffer because of it too and
it's like well duh well maybe it's not
that's not what we're going for it's
like well that's what's happening so you
know that's like why are we flashing why
are we doing that why Thank You Adam ah
thank you 9 7 4 9 James thank you
exiting thank you Matt mumble oh thank
you lunar syndicate Tatyana page bunny
chance counts ritika Shrek stray storm
dopey Tim plays thank you guys so much
see does YouTube ever talk to me I do
have a contact at YouTube I do so I've
got no complaints about that because my
contact at YouTube is wonderful her name
is Meg everybody give a big preesh in
chat to Meg at YouTube meg is the saint
of YouTube oh now what happened
amanda wis how am i doing today I'm
doing great we will all follow you to
the new channel if you start woman i
don't let's not jump to conclusions but
i've done it before and i know you guys
are absolutely so supportive and I could
always thank you guys for that and I was
and I know that if I had to start a new
channel like that doli be fine I don't
think that's situation here I think
that's just this is me being like
hyperbolic but everybody give a big
preach to Meg because meg is super super
super awesome very communicative and
very amazing let everybody give lots of
love to Meg lots of hearts to Meg in
chat right now yeah so anyway that's but
but it's just like other things like
that do happen like to kind of fall
apart like that if I had to start a new
channel let's just not even go into the
hypothetical questions of like having a
certain your channel cuz I don't think
that's that was just hyperbolic this
don't worry about that if it does happen
I like I'll let you know when we'll
cross that bridge when it comes but
that's probably not what's going to
happen so let's not even think about
that YouTube will sort itself out and
all will be well and good in the world
yeah it's all three cheers for Meg hip
hip hip hip hip hip rude I think you
should have played missed that 100 Mario
challenge with how much rage I've been
played Mario maker in ages and frankly
I'm glad my my blood pressure is really
benefited from me not having the - Mario
maker
thank you skinny buttons think he
doesn't--he krobak Thank You Brandon
Fitz Thank You DC be Titan thank you
Jonathan Parker thank you deadly
definitely hunter think he pulls too
nasty Thank You faith aver grab a bowl
thank you guys so much
all right so we're looking a little bit
better here I want to crap out this one
we're doing good on oxygen we're doing
good on power we're doing good on
research is almost done taking a while
though
oh no what happened oh no what was that
Michael sward love your channel mark
your videos have helped me through my
hard times with getting out of the Navy
after five years well congratulations
for getting out of the Navy hope you're
adjusting to what is happening did you
just eat poop oh is that Turner what the
hell you just get the most disgusted
face I've ever seen in my life did you
just eat some poop oh god we're almost
out of food okay as soon as farming is
done we'll be able to get that up but
we're gonna be in trouble we're gonna be
in trouble I'm at have to eat these
shine bugs tasty shine boats it's also
got a water pump going here right
there that's probably good oh hi mark oh
hi hello I give up all I want is your
attention kiri Scott look there's even
if not everyone got a notification here
and even if it is less than what is
normally here there's still 15,000
people here I try my best I do what I
can
and I appreciate being here but I try so
hard and no I won't give shoutout to
channel that's not to the same person
that was someone else but no not gonna
do that occasionally I look at chat and
it's like why didn't I see that out of
all the things that pop up into my mind
I just see someone took their
opportunity in chat to type outcome is
that what I see I always like my eyes
naturally gravitate towards the like
like the the choke me - I'm just trying
to be like her Jenna I'm trying to
create a sensible nice chat Ryan
Christensen Thank You commander
hey Mark I would like to thank you for
being an inspiration in my life my
father passed away from colon cancer
when I was 16 your videos help me find
joy in life and I have to say hoorah
well thank you so much for that and I'm
so sorry that your father passed away
from colon cancer I definitely know what
that's like I lost my dad to lung cancer
when I was 18 years old and it was just
a rough time for me so but you will get
through it eventually and I hope you
have Ryan Kristensen $100 hopeful good
morning I hope you have a great day well
thank you for that and thank you
everybody that's like giving through
super Chad can you guys let me know in
no don't that's not what you're supposed
to type in chat mods ban mods or put
timeout bunch timeout we've stopped
we've started a bad presidents time have
a time about stop it it's a title stop
it stop the pure the purity the purity
of this chad has gone away stop in mods
help mods help help help
no I'm serious don't do that the mods
you have free rein to put people in
timeout for doing that that is just not
OK just cuz that was funny in one
situation doesn't mean it's going to
become
is gonna be coming just funny doesn't
mean it's gonna be funny in the long
term so let's just stop that now no no
no no put them in timeout you go on the
naughty corner you go on the naughty
corner everybody that spamming that gets
put in timeout hope it's worth it you go
in the naughty corner you go no you go
put in the naughty corner you go in the
naughty corner we don't want none of
that here we are a family friendly
stream we're a family friendly group you
are not being family friendly you are
not being family friendly you are gonna
be the reason that I get to monetize and
that's why I have to start a new channel
probably I don't know just everybody
hold on to your tits is a family
friendly stream hold on your tits held
them hold them real hard and just
everybody hold on because this is a
family not in this family friendly
stream family friendly oxygen not
included family friendly for as far as
family friendly can friendly be makes
sense okay get it you're on thin ice all
of you oh you're on thin ice right now
you better watch yourself you better
watch yourself real hard better watch
yourself cuz I'm I've had it up to here
I bet it up to here with you your
attitude your attitude needs work okay
alright I'm just gonna say that right
now alright looks good day's going let's
get the blossom seats to
we're not gonna have enough alright
research we need that okay can see you
know go told what was that you took a
bio test today thank you thank you
congratulations Joseph Cooper everybody
give it up for Justin Cooper Joseph
Cooper took a bio test today that's hard
that's raw you pulled through though you
good we're happy about that thank you
thank you thank you thank you Charlie
Ferguson I love watching you play this
game and seeing you turn to this chaos
into an orderly system gives me hope
that messes can be fixed what that is
that is just so delightful that's that's
really honestly truly delightful that's
so nice thank you I need oh I can't have
brittle blossoms yet I forgot about that
all right I'll get them later I'll just
plan meal wood for now but that's
honestly very wholesome like yes even if
things are chaos they can be turned into
into good things even if your chat start
spamming words they shouldn't spam
everything can be handle than everything
to be turned into kick like back into
normal nice chat it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be so panicky all the
time things can be nice and things can
be neat and things can be fun for
everybody to enjoy and that is what you
need to learn about this and that's what
needs to be said so that's important
that is important so thank you for that
and thank you Bri and awesome also thank
you to Kaylee Ferguson thank you to
scp-105 donate through to $50
oh no Thank You Victoria Sherri Thank
You Kaylee Ferguson singing jolly boots
of Doom fraid spencer HH Charlie
Ferguson Maya John Paul G Nathan King
Maya thank you so much
alright so that can we can we the chat
is fast but I could actually read this
somewhat I'm trying anyway but it's it's
going it's going there okay so we
haven't even reached any sort of the new
stuff yet because I'm just so slow
number one but just because I'm trying
to very very make sure that our basic
needs are met
I'm gonna fail and everybody's gonna
choke and die and no that's not a good
thing
okay oh I need oh god I need to do a big
label aureus cry cuz I need I built this
out one too close cuz I'm stupid
no I built it out too too close [ __ ]
okay so what I need to do is I need to
build another generator on the other
side over here and then I need to get
rid of that generator and then I need to
do this piece of [ __ ] whatever do
everything wrong because I'm talking to
you guys because I'm trying to lecture
you guys and you guys are throwing me
off with your daddy and your father and
your mommy and none of that we don't
want none of that here because I'm
trying to do this what I'm supposed to
do and you guys not being productive
members of society so let me do what I'm
gonna do and you you and you you gonna
you gonna hold on okay you just gonna
hold on and that's gonna be fine
and we're all gonna deal with this okay
we're family friendly this is a family
friend I'm gonna do strawpoll is this a
family friend
yes of course
[Laughter]
absolutely
new poll coming in HoN heavy in chat new
poll coming in you Paul knew Paul knew
Paul knew Paul Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw
Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw ball
okay it's family friendly right all
right back to the game what was I doing
here I don't even remember we're gonna
rid of that um I I made this way too
close I forget why but it was something
stupid no no what
all right Neil woods growing we're gonna
run out of food
real soon we are so dead or dead we're
dead I'm sure it doesn't help the panic
and scream that we're dead at the top of
my lungs but we're dead we're all gonna
die what is it okay wait what are the
results
Oh is winning no who's winning by 52%
god damn you you guys are just a bunch
of sassy [ __ ] yourse [ __ ] all in
every one of you that's gonna be the new
name of the fan base
welcome to the sass holes cuz that's all
you got these are every day of every
goddamn week it's just sass hole this
sass hole that hosue can out sass sass
er man oh yeah Oh welcome to this
[ __ ] here's your sass hole shirt you
got your sass whole tattoo it's just a
big butt hole this is a big butt hole
the sleeve of your shirt that's all it
is anyway can someone make its own make
it could someone make someone draft up
ass [ __ ] like shirt
can we get ass [ __ ] like club banner
can we get this [ __ ] flap
like I didn't feel like I need that in
my life I've never I've never felt like
I needed anything more until this very
moment I I needed sass well man it's
good sass whole emoji I'd get bad so
fast it's gonna be a bud twitch you get
like banned if you get like a if you get
like um like a your butt and mode is to
button like this super simple and it's
gonna be like it's just it's just lips
it's just it's some one person their
lips real close that's all it is
God give me my channel back like this is
the real reason I'm gonna have to start
a new channel is because mine could be
because of its own please can someone
please create a SAS emoji for me I will
attempt to put it up and if it gets me
banned it's your fault I'm not joking
I'm gonna try this I'm gonna try this
someone I don't like yeah they like the
kissy lips from Ashley right they're
like the kissy lips but just a butthole
a kissy but it's just the wrong lips
it's the southern lips
welcome to the family friendly and it'll
be fine so someone draft that up someone
really good at art put their really good
art - don't you dare it's too late it's
happening great can it have sassy arms
sorry you mean like one of these can we
like one of these things like just me
when I was in the day with marklar you
just I don't know if that could be put
into an emote but you do our best we're
gonna die we have no food I oh I'm in
the way our night I've totally forgotten
that I've been in the way of the
important data
time alright so I'm gonna drop this down
cuz you guys haven't been able to see
I'll put it right here there we go see
that's nice now you guys can see the
important information that you
definitely really need to see I'll put
it right there so you can see any alert
that's happening yeah that's good right
it just messes with me because it's not
in the top-left or the bottom left and
is like we'll keep it there keep it
there for you thank you you're welcome
you're welcome everybody look I'm a
professional streamer I'm a professional
family friendly streamer I don't like
those lips no no where everyone's
finding these lip emojis but that's not
ideal in any capacity all right I'm
gonna get a new duplicate in here
because Yolo I guess Liam is dumb but
Liam's got this looks like Ethan is
anybody else seeing this this looks like
Ethan right here nobody else seeing this
a slow learner yep that seems about
right a divers lungs from his gymnastics
training farm cook and tidy are his
interests but he never manages to
execute on I and he alright come on
we're bringing the stress reaction
vomiter yep news Ethan all right perfect
[Laughter]
alright we got it hey the family's all
here maybe Turner all right hey you're
not turning anymore you're your tile it
says Tyler
Nisbet well just keep we got Tyler and
we got Ethan so the now the question is
which one's gonna die for that's the
only question I got Tyler was the one
eating
yeah it's aller was the one eating poop
that is absolutely true Tyler and I
think we can all confirm Tyler was in
fact eating poop I think we all saw it
we all saw it it's the truth we can't
deny the truth when the truth comes out
the truth comes out when the poopy truth
comes out the poopy truth comes out the
rumor has come out does Tyler eat
don't forget Wade well we only got girls
left in here at the moment wait is that
wait
Otto cool he's got an afro it suede
suede suede when back in high school
Tyler's poop farming the poopy truth
yeah you know like that documentary An
Inconvenient Truth does come all my fans
are furries I doubt that incredibly but
then the bull Murray just took a tumble
but then again I don't have anything to
dispute that so maybe it's true we can
always do a poll
I like polls now let's do a poll let's
let's put this to the test
ah we're gonna we're gonna go alright
here we go here we go here's the pole
new pole good for coming in hot Navi new
pole new pole Nepal is you a furry new
poll new poll new poll new poll all
right let's do that see what happens I
mean I'm just like a bad news maybe
maybe I don't know I've never pulled in
that capacity before so maybe the truth
will come out finally calling out it's
getting cold in here
ah that's getting cold by the way on the
poll the answers are you fan knew you're
eating check ramen with makeshift
chopsticks what like you've picked up
two twigs from outside and that's what
you're eating thank you to Blue Rose
Aaron Lee obsidian assassin mark my
cucumber needs to be noticed
please notice my juicy cucumber also you
are trees stop being a cave man you know
I love Lowell random everybody who
doesn't love Lowell random Lowell random
is just how is my GU doing with Ethan
Thank You dispenser with a eggplant and
a water Butchie me me winters Nikki akan
Chloe Rooney fuzzy magic joy Kade
doodles stuff Creon lisby thank you so
much thank you
alright let's see what's the results
[Laughter]
it's largely split it's it's it's 57%
new and a 43% youth well then I guess
the truth does come out we're dying [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] all right well we're dying but
oh well what can you do about it man
all right let's uh let's let's harvest
that okay let's try it well we can't get
it fees unreachable mmm well we've done
goofed it we goofed it pretty good here
we did a pretty good goofing on
ourselves so we need we need to somehow
undo this
we got an uncool fit we gotta somehow
it's right now it's really goofed and
then we gotta uncuff it okay we can do
this though let's build another toilet
pull one more toilet and then I'm gonna
put another put another one of these
right there just so we catch it all the
poop I mean this should we catch the
poop on the way down I'm a research
interior decor how long till this 70%
we're gonna die we are gonna die oh
we're gonna die i'm goof-goof a shark
applier well that's better than all the
other names that you guys were coming up
with I suppose anyway yeah your internet
hates you don't worry we don't hate you
here we don't you crazy train notice me
senpai please read my message okay did
master crusader thank you so much
Eloy villains blaze Makara Gabrielle
Johnson where do we send digital art
Papa Shadow wrote Roxas you can't handle
the poop I don't think I can
thus a suppliers SAS whole yes I'm like
that do I like cats I like cats not as
much as I like dogs but I like cats I
like cats a lot Pole of death yeah
pretty much that's every pole we can
kill these hatches we're gonna eat their
tasty flesh definitely eat their tasty
flesh we can eat their delicious tasty
flesh mmm okay look it's a hack
boy we definitely these tasty delicious
hatches but I don't know if we eat the
hatches if they're gonna be gone forever
that's what I don't know I try to keep
things alive as long as I can but it's
not gonna work top five desserts
cheesecake key lime pie ice cream sundae
creme brulee molten chocolate lava cake
put that one at the top actually I like
that those are my top desserts then like
below that one of those popsicles the
rocket ones the red white and blue ones
cuz I love America please check out
Psychonauts I remember Psychonauts I've
never played it though like those big
games they just don't have time to play
for the ones that I want to actually
spend some time on or like this where
it's just a management game and I tried
to do that YouTube keeps freezing on you
no damn it
YouTube fixture oh man oh uh YouTube fix
your [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I've eaten
pineapple pizza I've eaten it all on
livestream you guys saw in our last you
guys saw I think you guys saw anyway
probably
[Music]
that's not supposed to happen that's not
supposed to happen there's not it it
doesn't take that my system that's not
supposed to happen there's a very rare
reserved one and that's not supposed to
happen like that because stream labs
you're misinterpreting what it is you're
not converting currencies properly so
don't mess with me okay good
don't do that don't do the messing with
me don't mess with me I will I'll stab
hi you're stuck aren't you reveal the
hatch okay so these are almost done I'm
probably gonna need to make more algae
terrariums now so that's kind of cool
but I don't
[Music]
ah why don't I go I don't remember what
I was gonna do I can't even remember
what I was doing about that what are
they doing I've completely forgotten
jobs board oh yeah all right good jobs
going
I like jobs yeah
nope yeah what are you doing up there
what are you guys doing up there guys be
a little more productive you guys aren't
being very productive I don't like it
okay that's not supposed to be there get
rid of those oh I'll put this y'all put
this yeah yeah and yeah and dig out all
that and yeah okay okay
potatoes are soggy because if I didn't
read the rest of that meant frankly I'm
glad I didn't because I didn't want to
do you like the dark I mean I don't like
the dark I like going for a run at night
I actually did go for a run at uh last
night right at sunset I've started
running lis recently and I'm just for
some reason I really really like it it's
something extremely enjoyable for me and
and I don't know why because I've never
thought that I would like running before
III made it very public that I actively
hate like running and so no that's not
right oh thank you
that's not suppose that I swear that is
not supposed to happen because stream
Labs doesn't take into account currency
stream labs god damn it I want to like
you I want to like you so much but geez
you are just not cool right now you're
not being cool you're not being cool
Thank You Decker oh god I'm just law I'm
full of rage full of indignant rage all
the time that's all I am and that's all
I've ever got is just indignant rage
just the world and all the whole society
trying to beat me down but I won't let
it as I am strong
we got meal wood and that's
good let's make some more we're probably
gonna need more anyway so okay so we got
those I'm gonna play a meal within there
yeah food shortage I'm aware they're
just pulling the they're pulling the
larvae right off the tree and they're
munching it right in their mouths oh no
what happened Erick bill icky hello from
Hawaii mark love you you doof is this
for charity today no it's not for
charity today sorry about that it is not
for charity that's why I'm like don't
worry about giving me anything not at
all thank you to joshua mastery
Elizabeth less cold decker O'Brien Jamin
347 relly o-net Nathan Sierra Goss
Rachel Rogers Alexander Grubbs and
Alexander Grubbs again you are my idol
please knows me thank you you have any
tattoos no I don't have any tattoos I'm
not a tattoo kind of guy random question
what is my favorite soda I don't really
drink soda I drink these like Arnold
Palmer's which are half ice tea and half
lemonade if you've ever had them and
they're good can you say hello to my
nephew Mason cherry hello Mason cherry
are you doing Britney Lutz in home
thanks so much
okay so as you can see in front of us we
have chaos in hell in all sorts of Hell
have I tried milk tea I hate milk tea I
don't like tea in general but I like
Arnold Palmer it is a nice balance but I
don't like tea and I hate milk tea I
hate boba I don't want chunks I don't
want it because whatever I mean drinking
boba I just get this weird feeling that
someone vomited in my tea
that's all I gots all I get out of it I
don't get like the who tasty little
squishy balls of yogurt no I get like
there's vomit in my teeth then that's
all I feel the entire time that I'm
drinking it so I'm like please don't
vomit in my tea I don't want that let's
just not have that you know what I mean
so this is not bother with it and it'll
be fine
but for now I don't like tea but I like
Arnold Palmer's which is half iced tea
and lemonade
who the hell did that you will rule
midnight wolf well thank you so much
love from Norway love to Norway as well
thank you see one of my favorite book I
don't have a favorite book I don't have
a book that it like I just go back to
every time just because like I can't be
bothered with that like I wish I could
be bothered with it but I just can't be
bothered with it did you just drop that
oh god because of all the carbon dioxide
okay well I really did a goof I really
really did a goof here cuz I didn't get
nearly enough anything to be able to do
what I wanted to do so I really goo for
this super duper hard but that's okay
because I think it's okay so long as I
say it's okay it's probably okay I think
anyway yeah whatever
it doesn't even matter walk the co2 no
the sea oats is fine I'm gonna walk the
co2 later on because of the slimes if I
can ever get to that point which I will
cuz I'm very smart stop laughing I am
very very smart are you done yet Jesus
once this is done I'm gonna get the next
power thing in there not there we go and
then I'm gonna get the power regulation
get that where's my job board did I
break but not built my job board god
dammit I didn't build my job god damn
nerd we're gonna make a break room this
is the break room no this is the break
room now I got it I'm a smarty no that
is not the break room this is the break
room got it I'm smart so smart god damn
I'm just a good old smarty I'm just a
big smart man smart is what I am and
smart is what I do I'm
Marx and goddamn I have just smart look
at my big brain and mind baby I am so
goddamn smart I'm just smarter ever
smart I am a smarty and I'm full of
brain make up my mind I've got I've got
it I've got another poll no I'm not
gonna do a poll asking whether I'm smart
or not cuz I already know the answer
you're all gonna say that markiplier he
is the smartest smart that ever smarted
in the history of smart he is smart
beyond smart he's so smart he is
unbelievably smart if there's any one
man that is smart beyond smart it is
that man and that man right there is
smart that's what you'd say we all know
this so actually you know what I'll do
I'll do a straw poll I'll do a straw
poll like is Mark smart of course duh
yes sure no all right so we got a nice
poll coming up here am i smart I'm
pretty smart I'm pretty smart guys guys
poll incoming poll is now exploding in
chat right now look am i smart obviously
duh of course dull yeah you know I am
you know where's the pull everyone shut
up you shut your mouth
you shut your mouth cuz I'm not gonna
deal with all that okay who wants to dig
Gausman is the best at digging so I'm
gonna make it Gausman the dig Mary is
the best at building
gopher Tyler is definitely a gopher okay
Wade is apparently the smart one which
waitis weight is very smart okay general
engineer what does that even mean
operator we don't need that okay anybody
good at farming we don't need that yet
whoo we got Ethan and wait Ethan wants
to farm doesn't he well maybe Ethan a
farmer
seems like Ethan or Ethan could be the
tidy guy we don't have we don't need a
cook yet can is bet Oh Kane is bet is
the art-student apparently gained his
bet you're an artist you're very good at
it so you're gonna do it
but morale requirements are morale is
super low that's not let's not do that
not yet anyway we don't need those you
don't need those we just need a little
bit and then we need some general
purpose stuff that's all we need Oh
stupid all right once this poll say you
guys get the results of the poll you get
something I like why did you pick that
one I mean I'm glad you agree that I'm
smart but why did you pick him daddy why
did you pick that one that was not the
one that you were supposed to pick that
was not the one that you needed to pick
why in the world would you pick that one
and why is no papa in second place white
it's 29% you think that I'm not smart I
mean that's obviously a minority but I
just don't it was a perfectly good of
course done yes sir yes sirs at the
bottom you put my daddy on the top no
that's terrible
you're Tarrant you're terrible you're
just terrible cuz your sass holes and
whatever whatever all right so I guess
we got that going on for us which is
wonderful thank you
for that where can you find the pole the
pole is inside your own butthole just
explore deep and you'll find it thank
you to classical gingered ugly rancid
drop bear panda gaming the Taos
Alexander grubs that emo trash oblivious
protag V monkey plays Elizabeth allez
cult
oblah oblivious protag emo Jack Edie and
remember we got a special announcement
coming out tomorrow tomorrow there's
gonna be a very special announcement
don't this that's not James thank you
Sam's again dropping this in hopes I'm
in the Navy and the one thing we
commonly do is exchange in Clark
challenge two coins I made a gaming
inspired coin is impossible to send you
one as a gift I don't have any way to
get a gift I'm sorry about that I just
don't I don't have any sort of Peel box
I don't take any gifts and stuff like
that thank you I appreciate it but
unless you meet me in person in some day
and you just happen to have it on you
that is the only way that you could
possibly give it to me okay make sense
all right let's do this
what were we doing why am i paused I'm
not supposed to be pause what are you
doing we need we don't need another one
we definitely don't need another one
well what we do need is food we are
going to die we are going to die we have
no food oh all right okay all right okay
all right okay okay there's food down
there but that's unreachable let's see
okay oh we're gonna die all right so we
might die here did I make that clear we
might die this this might be this might
be die this might be die we might be die
but that's okay cuz oh we might be dying
there seems to be a lot of little things
up here along with some pepper plants
and some water
[Music]
but we might be died okay well we got to
do is we got to go a like a strict
strictly go for the goodies that are
here let's dig around this thing let's
not go there let's dig these out this
out then we're gonna go down run dig
this out hope for the best
there's a lot of goodies down here maybe
some food okay go for that there's some
goodies over here here and there
there's goodies here and there okay so
far so good
as goodies and hopefully some of this is
actually food and we're not gonna die
how's that feel for how's that good yeah
it's good you know I'm good I know what
I'm doing Thank You Katie be thank you
Jolly boots of doom Thank You stunning
tonight out Thank You blue rose thank
you James quiet Kowski Thank You Kelly
sparrows thank you classy ginger thank
you Doug Lee alright we've got this
maybe probably don't got this but we're
gonna try our best oh they don't have
any oxygen down there and that's gonna
be it's gonna be tough to deal with I
wish I could create just a big vent to
go straight down to the bottom but we've
got already problems to deal with right
here Hey okay that is some food there's
indeedy-do some foods so some food is
better than none food so that's good to
go let's take out this here not that one
oh let's stick out let's cancel let's
put the big cancel on yeah no that's
fine that's fine down there it's only
one person going after
anyway I know we got a food shortage I'm
aware of the fact that we have a food
shortage let's go for these let's go for
the taxi let's go for these that looks
about it man we then we should be held
over long enough for the meal wood to
grow and then we can get a nice steady
food to supply and then we're gonna be
good to go I don't like the fact that
those are there right now but that's
okay because we got to deal with that
while we got to deal with that okay
all right you don't know how to send
pictures in chat are you talking about
the emotes I have no idea so [ __ ] it
okay wait wait a minute
you are an idiot you are an idiot stop
what you're doing think think think
rationally about this now how would you
get out of this situation
that's how you would you can also dig
that out
there you go there you go are you stupid
you big stupid dummy dumb head and you
dumb stupid stupid you dumb stupid
stupid he stupid I'm glad you're live
Gausman but you're so stupid you're just
a big stupid dummy dummy Oh close one
stupid I know stupid stupid I know
stupid I hired him what nah stupid
what's stupid do I play piano no no I I
do not have I died yet oh I see how it
is oh you think that I'm just gonna you
thinking I'm just gonna wheel over and
die ha you think that I'm gonna you
think that you think that I'm gonna just
fall over and die uh no the answer is
absolutely not and I'll thank you for
not assuming that I will know what I
mean
thank you to redneck gaming Tony Davis
Marisa Miller
Kiril Mar Azov Tobi's the Taos Brandon
Richardson Nero one zero zero six Skylar
King and God apparently ah thank you so
much I think the burrito sec thank you
so much for what you do please keep
being amazing good night I'm not reading
the end of that let's just assume it
ended pleasantly and not the way that it
did all right
so what we got to do now is kind of
level I just want to give him a busy
work to do all the research is finished
now the research did finish okay the
research has finished so we got that
going for us we got a little more base
here
blam okay we got a lot of base which is
good but we don't have a lot of stuff to
do with the base just yet which is fine
I guess are you sleeping do you
socialize who'd you socialize with have
no idea no whatever
all right let's build this out here -
there there and there excavation project
it was a nice clean place okay doodlee
doodlee did a little thank-you KTB thank
you saw see ya sir hi I'm a huge fan
from Iraq it's been difficult to live
here and I just want to thank you for
helping me through appreciate you thank
you so much and man I I have no idea
what it's like over there but if it's
tough for you I'm so sorry about that
yeah alright spooderman where do you see
spooderman unless he's moving anywhere
anywhere oh by the way if you weren't
here at the beginning of the stream
there's a special announcement coming
out tomorrow be on the lookout for that
I've been working with someone that you
know on a special project and it's
finally ready to talk about so we're
gonna talk about it
finally but for the time being it
announces tomorrow and if YouTube
decides to not be a horrible son of a
[ __ ] in terms of notifications and not
telling anybody that anything is
actually happening then you'll get
notified about it and that'll be pretty
cool but in the time being you'll have
to wait for tomorrow oh did I not change
the thumbnail oh oh did I not change the
thumbnail oh God everybody change your
answers on the poll - I'm stupid did I
not oh god I didn't thank you thank you
for letting me know all of you guys were
here this whole time being like a little
it's a weird scary thumbnail for oxygen
not included well thank you for that now
it's better god damn it is it better now
I don't know how you'd be even be able
to tell I don't even know how you'd be
able to tell somebody go to my main
channel page and just see refresh that
see if it's changed I don't know god
damn it I'm such a tool well alright
okay so I don't know maybe maybe I don't
even deserve to be on YouTube because I
just don't understand
works at this point there's so many
times that they just absolutely forget
everything what time tomorrow
I think noon pacific standard time is
gonna be a special coordinated video
upload from me and another guy and
you're gonna see it it's gonna be great
but it's fine
did you know YouTube was hacked if it
was that's wonderful I don't know it
probably doesn't affect me at all but
that would explain why everything's
absolutely broken but the fundamental
problem is I shouldn't be on sets
platform it's my level of smartness okay
what am i doing I have no idea
this place looks too big I think plays a
little too big I think I've got a
problem just a little bit too big it's a
little bit too big just a little bit too
big I think I might have an issue a spy
fine I think it's okay it might not be
okay
is probably fine that's okay I don't
even know what I'm trying to do now I'm
just trying to stay the same at this
juncture okay looks like it changed okay
good now the crisis is over and
everything's good still scary no it's
not clickbait no it's just me being
stupid I'm not clickbait you'll know
when it's clickbait and you guys don't
even know what clickbait is I know what
clickbait is I've used clickbait but now
I'm not click baiting that's not it it's
changed okay good
Oh soon until this is done okay so soon
after that's done I'm gonna build my
power banks up north and get that going
and then we're gonna start in I want to
build them up top because I want the the
power to be fully of it with that is so
much algae oh hell yeah
look at all that oh hell yeah okay but
in the meantime I need to get like all
the basic fundamental stuff going power
play in greenhouse I don't have a farm
station so I couldn't do that anyway
let's see okay I can make this into a
bedroom but the stress isn't even there
yet the stress isn't something that I'm
worried about the point still the same
after several refreshes well look I
don't know just I was just I'm trying
man I'm trying to change now I'm trying
I hear I can't make everything perfect I
can't make everything pristine I'm just
one man I'm one incredibly handsome
smart man ah thank you and remixes thank
you risk star Thank You KTB new taco
Samuel Beeler Miss blood glove music
chick do an Dupin Katie be saucy assert
the Taos do and upin burrito sec there
you I'll probably read some of those
already but thank you see it's better
right it's better now if the
notification system is better yeah Oh
for anyone asking like what's wrong with
YouTube I don't know
I don't know what specifically is wrong
overall with YouTube but there's
obviously some problems going on there's
a lot of us that's sleeping oh my god so
I don't know what's going on with
YouTube in general but there is
something wrong fundamentally I haven't
heard any news about it specifically but
nobody panic and say that YouTube is
going to die soon it's not dying it's
just has some problems now just because
it has some problems doesn't mean that
everything is hunky-dory but it's
nothing worth panicking over just so
everyone understands that nobody go
spreading rumors about how like it got
super hacked unless they were solid
evidence about that my channel is not
going to blow up my tails that wou
hasn't lit in a while but my channel is
not gonna blow up don't worry about that
that's not the whole situation here it
is fine everything is fine McKenzie
Anderson hey Marcus McKenzie I'm the 11
year old who donated last time still
love you can you do you have a hundred
dollars to donate well thank you but I
double check with your parents about
that I'm double check double check with
your parents about that if that's okay I
don't want to get in trouble or anything
like with your parents because if you
just you know I'm just saying you know
what I mean
make sure that you could give that if
you can and I don't need it in the first
place but I want to be very clear you
don't have to and you don't need to and
make sure you can't so thank you but
we're sure okay all right I don't know
oh yeah back to YouTube um there's a
problem with the notification system
obviously the members who haven't been
getting notifications on post I don't
know when that's gonna be fixed
I don't know when anything's gonna be
fixed so just pay attention tomorrow
because I'm gonna try my best to like we
are gonna try our best to announce it to
everybody as possible if it doesn't get
to you
we're trying to rest but sometimes it
just doesn't work and then
now we'll just do what we can when we
can okay this is going to be the battery
room that's okay I know how to fix that
cuz it'll be like I meant to do it the
entire time
oh hell yeah that way we can have a ton
of batteries in a big room and it'll be
super sweet yeah big battery Junction
coming up hot and heavy oh hell yeah
I love big batteries I like batteries
battery batteries batteries batteries
nice YouTube has its headedness ass oh
my god YouTube's gonna die well there
you go okay no the YouTube is not gonna
die nobody panic about YouTube dying
it's just going through a phase it's
just got a phase that's all it is it's
growing up something's going on and just
cuz we don't know doesn't mean you gotta
go caused a ruckus ruckus is are nice
everybody loves a good ruckus but for
now we'll just leave it as it is and
everything will be good now let's put
Ethan back in the farming position and
let's put Wade back in the research
position so what we're gonna do now is
I'm gonna destroy this stuff here I'm
gonna make the generator production area
probably up here I'm gonna put two of
these bad boys one on either side and
we're gonna connect them with wire I
don't have any sort of transformer yet
so I can't do that just yet but I will
eventually
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay you need food I know we need
food we've got food don't worry about
foods we got Ethan on the job as far as
like actually making food so we're good
to go on that don't worry about it let
me worry about it you don't worry about
it cuz we all go I [ __ ]
I [ __ ] it up I [ __ ] it up I [ __ ]
it up I [ __ ] it up get out of there
get gone-gone cancel that cancelled
cancel this whole side cancel it all
cancel it destroy it breakdown
cancel it cancel it I but I'm a [ __ ]
idiot oh I'm an idiot but that's okay
because I can forgive myself because I
like to forgive forgiving is in my
nature
forgiveness is recipies forgive myself
okay it's fine when can you add it get a
new character in the game I could get
one right now but I don't have enough
food or oxygen to even deal with that so
I'm not gonna deal with that right now
and I'm not gonna worry about that I'm
just gonna I have what I got to do what
I got and that's it so as soon as I'm
able to get these up and running I'll
run the power up to the batteries and
I'll worry about I'll worry about I'll
worry about getting the various
junctions and power bridges and all that
[ __ ] I'll worry about that later
right now this is all I need to worry
about right now so I'm gonna leave this
right here right now
it's cozy time everybody it's time to
get cozy sure everybody cozy up cozy
down cozy up get nice and cozy like you
know know I'm not gonna notice you if
you call me daddy I'm not gonna do it
I'm just not gonna do it didn't chat
freeze as chat died nothing Chad died
chat working
eysan chat working over here hello hey
bones your it's frozen hello
a good day hello oh it's broken okay
chats broken over there so I gotta look
over here now
good thing I got two chats up anyway oh
that is super broken alright well we're
just gonna okay Oh more about I I don't
this thing if you're asking me about
what's going on with YouTube I don't
know I have no idea what's going on with
YouTube I wish I did
cuz I would like to know myself but
there's a problem with the notification
system there's a problem with like
getting videos out to people there's a
problem with accessing YouTube in
certain respects don't worry about it
don't panic about it
everything's very likely funny okay
that's all I know if you if you want to
know more I don't know
okay let's get this to Blair whoa not
that let's hook up this here this is
what I call a battery makes it I don't
have you got knew that but this is uh
these are batteries hope you do that
okay
and I think that's good there there's
not enough material to restore the base
well what do you mean there's not enough
material to restore the base is plenty
of material to restore the base
everything is fine in the base
everything is going down to present--
fine chat broke down on you too yeah I
wouldn't be surprised
well see the thing is another secret
about YouTube they push updates on
YouTube every week every or every two
weeks every either week or two weeks
they push out a new update to the
entirety of it oh yeah
thank you it's a surprise Thank You
Dakota Heil Thank You Isaiah workman
Eliot s cady be sad Trash Can
falklands gamer Catina s Caffrey Aubrey
Elle plays grab knock the destroyer
Travis Anderson steam geek thank you so
much oh you were sleeping by the toilet
is it sup Tyler is that Tyler no it's
Ethan just wants to sleep let's over
there ah that makes sense but hey that's
Tyler's territory you don't eat poop
Tyler eats poop anyway gonna get a
better hat that he can see his uh C's
glorious blue hair alright so they're
gonna finish up this project and then
there the roof there then we're gonna
have our big Bongo battery system oh no
what happened oh no time unraveled
hi mark my name is Jacinda I'm a big fan
of your videos and I think you're an
absolutely amazing person I love you so
much I wanted to know if you'd ever
visit Texas whoo we went to Texas for
the first leg of our tour we went to
Houston and Dallas and people seemed to
not know that we went on this tour
around a whole bunch of cities and I'm
actually surprised to see how many
people don't know or remember that we
went to their city oftentimes that's
good because I don't know why there's
water there
but we did we were there when we were in
Tennessee - we were in Tennessee yeah we
were there - yeah but we're not going on
tour anymore after this I'm sad to say
the tour is going to be absolutely ended
after this we go to Australia and that
is the absolute last of the tour steps
that we're going on for the you're
welcome tour if you haven't seen the
tour documentary it's available on my
channel I the name is Martin Blair's
tour the movie it's a great almost
feature-length documentary hypothermia
will just clean it up ya doof Ethan ya
doof by whatever they're for this a
minute okay so we got food that's good
we got that that's good I should
probably build some sort of like an
actual cookery that seems like something
that I should do but it's it's just a
lot of work then I gotta build like a
mush bar maker and I don't want to do
that it's a whole bunch of [ __ ] also I
need some sort of transformer or
something like that yeah well don't
matter I'm gonna make I'm gonna make the
new research station actually I'm gonna
do the opposite of this I'm gonna get
rid of this and I'm gonna get rid of
these batteries I'm gonna connect up for
now I'm gonna connect up this I need to
disconnect this later
just like when I remembered to do that
but I'm not gonna remember to do that
and then everything's gonna blow up and
I would be like hi why is everything all
blown now Wade Neath and I knew we'd
need some we're gonna be stressed god
dammit of course they are they're not
even doing their jobs anyways yeah you
know Wade even you're fired you're fired
get out of there you're fired I don't
need the stress I don't need the stress
to deal with it I don't need your stress
I don't need my stress you get out of
that you deal with it later I'm gonna do
what I'm gonna do and you're not gonna
deal with anything that I'm doing it
yeah you're always stressed poor Wade
dang you think it's absolutely no
respect
I respect Ethan just as much as Ethan
deserves to be respected and that's a
lot no wait no what's the opposite of a
lot that's a little bit that's all it is
thank you Kaufman's keep I'm looking
forward to the return of creep a pyre
for huniepop - also how many people have
you talked to with the texty thinking
probably a hundred or so maybe more
like I don't have a lot of time for it
but you got to remember there's there's
400,000 numbers in there I can talk to a
few a day and that's about it
I just tried to say hi and I try not to
blast out too many messages but I do
have plans for it don't worry about it
I have plans for it soon things don't
materialize overnight I've got things in
the work don't you worry your pretty
little heads over launch the nukes
why would I launch the nukes it's cocked
over boys okay you're right but I don't
appreciate that you're right I think
that that's nothing
Thank You Dakota Collins Thank You
Denise Danae Zia call Thank You Katelyn
seating and what does fell
what's booze pooping oh you're pooping
Oh poop okay good bye poop there's a ton
of goop down there that I need we get
any art I don't think we got a new yard
yeah whatever okay we got our batteries
that's good that's a lot of power
nice I like her beautiful
big beautiful batteries big beautiful
batteries
huh food shortage still goddamnit is
this really not enough food
how many system mush realize that's we
are in a tizzy about meals ok we need to
get ventilation as the last one then we
can get pressure management then we can
start going down into the depths of hell
and then we can keep things moving are
you sick are you honestly sick what's
the germ situation how are you sick you
weak baby uh uh hate some peanuts what's
going on there oh thank you Anna
Hollingsworth I've been a massive fan of
you since seventh grade now I'm the
first year of university that's a long
time your videos have got me through
middle school and I was going I want to
say thank you love you so much thank you
Thank You Erin Beltran thank you to
Caitlyn see if they udinese a call with
Dakota Collins Rockman candy um thinking
Jimmy Carter Bymark gonna catch some
sleep now gonna have to do the AH
messiahs work tomorrow very nice Sarah
Hart is there a high mark you brighten
my day every day I wish you could meet
you have a hug and tell you how amazing
and important you are in this world I
think it would cry well no need for that
because it's half lies Sarah Goldman
thank you so much will you come to
Sweden some time we were in Sweden
simply Scott did you have log books on
tour no does that mean log books now we
didn't try anything down I have no idea
what you're talking about
I wish I did but I don't he's a good
power that power of that okay
for the time being that's that's gonna
have to be enough we're gonna get the
Advanced Research after this one so we
can get the next step which we need oh
wait all these require basic research
now that is really helpful thank you for
that
alright then I'm just gonna get two
stations blown okay perfect so let's get
this like that that
that I'm just planning for the future
I'd like to do that that that that fix
the wires from the generator no it's not
time for that you don't need to remind
me that now I know it back I'm getting
it
mark EMU is one of the sexiest cows out
there that is that is a that is so sweet
that is the nicest thing anyone's ever
said to me
also how dare you I was in Denmark not
Sweden
when we night in Sweden is written Oh
everybody hold on who are we not in
Sweden I can't even remember half of the
places that we went to but were we not
in Sweden I thought we were in Sweden
were we not everybody stop everybody
hold on everybody stop just everybody
hold on where are we or were we not in
Sweden
but yeah we went to Deborah I thought we
would we definitely weren't weave we
weren't Sweden we weren't we'd just cuz
we went to Denmark doesn't mean that we
didn't go to Sweden who's the Denmark
Ian over there that thinks that we just
went that Denmark enough
I knew we went to Sweden we went to
Sweden we were in Sweden we went to all
three we went to swin Denmark in Norway
we went to him we were there and we were
there we were there we were there all
right we were there we were there Thank
You hyena fan please do a charity stream
for the animal hope and wellness
foundation someday right here in Sherman
Oaks I've done numerous animal charities
we'd love to do one again River Ramos
Caitlin sea thank you so much ah green
tea Jennifer s Jane Fowler a Caitlyn
seed this is a long shot but maybe
remember the poem I sent you for a mail
a long time that's time ago I got an A
on it and you read it everything
everything you could come to Albuquerque
oh I don't remember the poem right off
the top of my head but thank you for the
poem and I'm glad you got an A
thank you outreach from Zane all right
so they're good they're our batteries
have a lot of battery okay
larger batteries hold my power to keep
systems running longer before recharging
they're very barely losing any we are
still low on food how the Frick are we
still low on food these are doing
nothing for me I think I got to just
make I gotta make like one more and it's
gonna be brittle blossoms so we're gonna
make one more it's gonna be brittle
blossoms the door here I don't know why
I'm bothering with the door but I feel
it feels good you know so that's the
only explanation that I need okay I need
the bread little blah we're gonna get
the blitt allow them we got the little
blouses
I think that eliminate them all if that
doesn't illuminate them all then I'm an
idiot and I don't know what I'm doing
which is very very high popular this is
another wire I'm gonna fix that later
once I get the Junction's that's what
I'm gonna do that but for now it's fine
well heat production 1.25 k dtu's are we
still alive yes we're still alive why
wouldn't be we belie Mewtwo is broken
notifications are dead the entire
platform is going to crap so we got a
live stream because I can't even put up
a normal video because no one's gonna
see it
hey also I'd like the stream is so
choppy can't watch mark put it in a
lower resolution sounds like you or your
connection isn't fast enough I'm
streaming an ultra-low latency because
that way I can interact a little bit
better here we're not live anymore
don't you like ventes org but will you
lie don't you lie Thank You Jacob Gorman
Joe Zee Bieber angel lights out of reach
then thank you so much okay so they've
got power going up there the two of
those is not gonna do a lot for it right
now we're just in maintenance mode we're
gonna get drill blossoms in here blossom
seeds blossom seeds blossom seeds seeds
blossom seeds I've got more blossom
seeds down in the watery depths of hell
down there which is unfortunate cuz I
can't reach them
or whatever I wish I wish I didn't do
this why did i do why did you guys let
me do this why did you let me do this
nightmare of a thing hey you guys just
stood by and allowed me to do this
monstrosity here and frankly you know
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm disappointed that's
all it's all I gotta say I'm just I'm
just absolutely disappointed in you guys
I think that you guys you guys allowed
this to happen you should have known
better and you know I'm just I'm very
very disappointed in you guys all I
gotta say about that that's all say but
you know just like
you shouldn't know better than let me do
something that obviously was not a good
idea so I blame you and yeah really you
don't have any light over there you
stupid piece of crap you're really gonna
be like that look don't have light
what's what's light I don't know what
light is whatever though can I just like
why can't I just set all of these to do
everything here we should get showers in
here that's definitely the best idea
that we got so far oh that's your
sanitation I like sanitization
I like sanitation sanitation is good if
you delete the channel what will happen
to our memberships I don't know I'm not
gonna delete my tweet wait wait what is
the rumor that's people saying I'm gonna
delete this channel what the hell is
that all about I'm not gonna delete my
channel why would I do that even if I
stopped doing YouTube why would I delete
the channel that's not the situation
here who's thinking that I'm gonna
delete my channel
what the hell worth what is that why are
the lights flickering that don't delete
it mark I'm not deleting it in what
situation would I delete this [ __ ] I'm
not doing it don't have don't worry cuz
I'm not I'm not deleting it well where
did that rumors start I said he was a
joke at the beginning of a YouTube's
broken therefore I don't do it not the
situation that's not the situation all
right well let's put it to a strawpoll I
guess yeah let's put it to a strawpoll I
mean maybe I should you guys make a good
point like you should I delete my
channel yep first pepper yeah yep nope
nope yep nope there we go
here we go here we go new poll company
you've all come but this is the big
announcement for tomorrow's like I I
make a video this is very tearful video
starts out with like I have something to
sell you guys like or like oh this is
gonna be so hard he like or like I've
never done something this painful and
it's tears streaming down me in the
thumbnail and it's just gonna be like
I'm deleting my channel don't yeah
that's gonna be it oh god where we
flashing not well knop is only at a 63%
so that's a modest bump there could
definitely be an argument made to delete
it if 37% is saying - yep an okay
alright I got why I listen to that man
oh no delete channel delete my channel
you sure about that oh geez soul
morphine hi I'm mark on pregnancy I
binge watch a lot of your horror game
plays now two years later my daughter
recognizes your voice and has called you
Marky move twice start them early get
them subscribed when their toddler sign
him up for YouTube account
get him subscribe tie your friends to
chairs make him watch my videos that's
what I expect out of every single one of
my fans and if you guys didn't know that
when you were signing up for that you're
signing up to this level of commitment
then whoo boy you guys don't know what
you're on about because it is that level
of commitment here you gotta be willing
to pay in blood sweat and tears for
their CDs lights flashing that is the
minimum of what I expect from my fans
you got to be ready any moment any day
any time anywhere get some random
stranger off the street get him to
subscribe to my channel if you're not
spamming those likes valve subscribes
Andrew leaving a comment adding your
favorite the second a video comes out
what are you even doing with your life
not enough that's the answer I don't
even you don't even need to tell me what
it is in is not right because you're not
doing it right if you're not doing that
that's bad AJ to lota you need to eat
more cheese otherwise the world will end
I'm trying to cut back on cheese because
I I've been eating an unhealthy amount
of cheese and I'm trying to make sure
that I I don't die from cheese overdose
but I
trying to cut back I do love me some
cheese but just don't worry about it I
got it under control because all its
good to go
can we dig this out please you make this
a top priority dig we're really starving
here
we got like no food really really having
a tough time here we got to get Ethan
you are not farming hard enough where's
your hat
oh you're not a farmer anymore that's
right good they're doing that okay get
these meal ones in there cuz we're dying
here we're dying here
really die we've never been dying as
much as we've been dying right now okay
there we go all right we are close close
to the brink of death but that's okay
Louis will you notice me I just did
thank you thank you angels light Ariel
he'll AJ to lota Michael sworn Nico Paul
necro bunny put glow bugs in with the
blossom I can't whatever uh nacho
lover's soul morphine ghost dragon
theory thanks for helping me dumb down
everyday mark I that's insulting but
you're welcome thank you I guess but I
screw you I don't know I don't know what
to feel right now I've got so many
emotions sitting inside my heart I'm
gonna fix this because I hate those
faces what do we do we finish research
cool let's get
let's get I guess meal prep would be
good and cracker ooh okay I'll take that
I'll take the egg cracker then we can
put these guys to work can't wrangle
them up just yet but there's still [ __ ]
there's still pumping out eggs so we
gotta get that we'll get that and then
we'll make some more eggs and then we'll
taste them up they'll be nice and tasty
burn the building down okay that is a
bad idea let me just go ahead and say
that's a bad idea thank you storm Nova
dr. Kratts host
dreadknight Sarah Goldman Bionicle
angels light Ariel Hill that's a bad
idea
see Michaels wart can you do a charity
stream for Chris Kyle frog Foundation or
lone survivor Foundation I'm not taking
any suggestions on charity foundations
to raise money for I just want to make
that very clear I appreciate all of the
ideas that we have but right now I've
got so many things on my list that I'll
never be able to get through so as much
as I would like to say of course I would
love to do charity 4xyz I cannot and I'm
trying to I'm not not to be an [ __ ]
about that and I want to make sure
everyone understands I cannot do
everything and I definitely can't raise
money for all the Foundation's that I've
said I would put on my list raise money
for so I'm not taking any suggestions at
the moment please do continue to try to
raise awareness for them feel free to do
that but I cannot do everything I wish I
could but I cannot I've got another
charity event coming in November a big
one but that is something to see later
thank you though I do want to say thank
you thank you dragon tamer and Dawn who
is scared and Thank You Ariel Hill and
thank you Chris Herbert did you ever
come to the north-eastern your tear
I feel like Vermont and New Hampshire
always get left out we were up near
there not all the way up there though
fix your plant light oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay so research is coming along nicely
we're getting food it's not going well I
have to go to the bathroom so you guys
follow wait around for a little bit I
got I'll be right back I'll be right
back okay I'll be right back
okay I'm back thank you how did Wade do
he is inside Ethan okay that is not what
I expected to come back to but that
isn't exactly what's happening right now
yeah Marcus do you guys have any any
opportunity that you possibly can to say
that I'm dead it's every single moment
every single opportunity in the entire
world to say [ __ ] boys dead who's gone
forever I can't believe it so how fast
do I poop it's like a rocket it's like
it's like a potato launcher right out of
my butt and just overbearing description
of what it's like so I'm glad that I
could provide that for you yeah rocket
that's my favorite show on Nickelodeon
they're like in the past you know rocket
poop I remember that show very nicely oh
thank you William Ross hello from the UK
loved your tour when you visited
Nottingham and I loved being a member of
your channel have you ever watched
Eurovision and do you enjoy it never
watched it enjoy great British break off
I do love that one that is a good one
Great British Bake Off it's a great one
simply Scott Skylar King Allison ondru
sick soul morphine toddler has been
subscribed she know what this is about
she knows what she signed up for my
stomach called scummy hello person I see
on YouTube hello meme Lord I think that
stomach I'm not sure but I think its
stomach nothing wrong with us tummy no
now there's nothing wrong with it edge
is funny edge is funny to me oh god how
many people out there watch Great
British Bake Off if you don't you're
wrong is it
wonderful show wonderful show mm okay
god food is just an issue food is just
such an issue right now and it's because
of this horrible monstrosity why is that
Abbot
Michael chiraq mark you have a big heart
keep helping people you're good at it
don't forget to take care of yourself oh
I'm great I'm great if YouTube could fix
this [ __ ] I'd be super happy but you
know well it's broken I guess I'll just
make do with trying to be a big dumb
goof as much as I possibly can but in
the meantime I'm great I'm real great
why is it flossing again what are you
doing what do you know what are you guys
holes do it
what do you sass holds up to this time
that's bad Oh mr. Smith hey Mark love
your videos in Channel today I just got
out of basic combat training for the US
Army and only have today of freedom and
just so happens you're live streaming I
hope that I have the freedom with
catching up on your videos and your next
one love you mark well thank you so much
and congratulations for that and I'm I'm
sorry you're wasting your only day off
with me I don't know why you'd be doing
that but thank you nonetheless I'm glad
that I can provide some kind of
semblance of an entertainment coming out
of here okay so what I got to do oh
thank you die hyena X shadow blade ride
wizard mad wolf or the mechanical Fox
Michael shy Rock Chris Herbert amber
code Lagaan sole morphine Allison and
rusik thank you so much mm okay
we're gonna go pressure management
filtration air system it converts water
into oxygen and hydrogen well that'd be
nice but I got a got to create something
much much bigger and much more in-depth
before I do that okay they're going here
I'm gonna set this that's already it I
guess I got nothing else to do so why
not do that right oh do we have hygiene
ooh that's right we got to build a
shower
we're gonna build a shower all right
we're gonna build an industrial bathroom
and I'm and I'm actually what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually gonna turn this into
this is gonna be the new big Blanc and
basin that's what this is gonna be it's
a technical term for it anyway
think big bonk and basin it's gonna be
the dumb
it's gonna be the dump for so I'll just
leave that one there then it's gonna be
the dump necessary for the bottle emptor
rotate that okay and then this is gonna
be where the bad water was gonna go and
now I don't like that I want to be one
up Breck time there we go
that's gonna go there and then we're
gonna get underway with that this is the
new update by the way this update just
came out today like a half hour before I
started streaming today that's when this
update came out I'm gonna be screaming
for like a little bit longer probably
another oh we're starving aren't we oh
we're not doing so good mmm I think
we'll be okay
I think we're gonna be okay
they got enough calories in their system
I think they're gonna be okay ooh I
think they're gonna be okay it's gonna
be close but I think they're gonna be
think they're gonna be all right dude I
do not like you you've been saying for
two hours that you haven't been doing
good on this game but yet you're still
alive well excuse you I've never said
once that I was not doing good at this
game i'm an oxygen not including not
including master and i'm doing great
ethan still needs a bed Ethan does not
deserve a bed to be perfectly honest
listens to be perfectly honest with each
other even the last thing that he
deserves is a bed I think we can all
agree on that that is just absurd to
even think that he would have a bed so
let's not give him the bed and not give
him the benefit of a bed and we're gonna
be final right yeah well let me actually
dig these up uproot that because I can
probably relocate them up here where the
light is oh that's all it's got food we
need to find food
I need them to go digging for this let's
try here first before we go there I'll
try this at least is there something
here and I want to find out what it is
all right let's try that it's gonna help
a little bit though I guess we can dig
here and if that works out then that
works out but if it doesn't work out
then we're gonna be screwed there's a
lot of carbon dioxide down here this is
so much carbon dioxide six slice plants
per person that makes sense that makes
sense
I've also got these brittle blossoms but
for now I think we're gonna have think
we're gonna be roughly have that once we
get done with this then we can build the
other things that we need or a
ventilation I'll worry about that later
because eventually I want to do a thing
where I've got a ventilation system
that's pumping ventilation to every
single room no I'm like a centralised
oxygen production Center and then
pumping out to everything around that
would be nice
give a shout-out to Jeremy and thunder
thank you so much Pena's I don't know
why I'd say that or shot that at the top
of your lungs so you adorkable sweetness
thank you John
sonic fan night hyena some Russian named
dollar vs. ruble Shannon Lewis derpy ins
true lick draws John Dixon Sylvia
loose ha kawaii cat girl Lady Deadpool
dawn whisker thank you so much
you made a sassy butthole emoji and you
tweeted it at me oh god I don't want to
see that careful you're gonna get your
Twitter account babe tweet and random
buttholes that everybody it's never
gonna work out for you gotta be careful
even stuck oh this is stupid
how is he stuck you stupid fool
you stupid fool you stupid stupid fool
peppermint you could move any any time
this
I
what are you doing what are you doing it
what are you do God why are you hanging
out oh I know why I know I know I know
why I know why okay I know I was I was
so confused okay I God are we done with
that okay we got that I was so confused
there I thought for a second and we need
to build the egg cracker and I guess we
might as well make a mess hall or
something like that let's make the mess
hall with it by later I don't know what
we're gonna do with it I want more mints
look I know this isn't the best thing
for me to eat on stream no no no the
eating on stream is kind of a bad thing
anyway but I'm gonna do it because I
just don't care remember I'm ass [ __ ]
and you all thus [ __ ] with me so
we're gonna get there praise the cheese
raisin cheese fish
Hey ladies Apple never heard of this
game what you do here never heard of
oxygen not included you've never heard
are those wonderful game called an
oxygen not included it was a great game
delightful game even the best game loved
this game it was made by the same people
that made don't starve what is happening
and it's just where you try to build the
base and try to not die that's the
general gist of it if you cannot die
that's doing pretty good and if you can
die then you're pretty much in the
average of the game played
hmm what am i eating I'm eating mints I
said that why are you listening god damn
can open up your goddamn ears okay it's
a kitchen different from the mess hall I
don't think it is
no one does real machines okay no that's
not different at all okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
all right okay I think I got this Markey
moose breath stank oh no it don't don't
spread rumors about that my breath is
pure minty deliciousness I could borrow
my breath and sell it that's how good my
breath is I could do it and people would
buy it don't think that people wouldn't
because people would OPP would love love
to get a hold of a jar of my breath
don't even think that we wouldn't who
they would love that raise your hand if
you'd buy whole time would you buy my
breath be honest because you will be
like would you buy my breath why are my
lights blinking yes yes no oh I hate fun
there we go
that's what I thought would you buy my
breath here comes here comes new Poland
Nepal Nepal Nepal Nepal Nepal oh yeah
you would know don't you
hmm oh that's bad
Kendall Bates my mark still doing Greg
keep up the oxygen ops and work not
reading the end of that one thank you so
much thank you bells Adana fear some
facts Stephen booth sorry
Preston [ __ ] soul morphine Lady
Deadpool fearsome facts stupidest theory
thank you so much where's the answer
what's the answer
exactly oh god that's a lot of people
saying they hate fun I sad for you that
you hate fun but that's a solid 50 58
percent of people that would buy my
breath who did that
Skylar King my phone is about to die so
I'm gonna leave thank you for all the
great videos stay healthy and tell chiku
I said hi well thank you for that
there's a lot of people that are telling
me to stay healthy I don't know why
something gonna happen soon with my
health it's the only thing I could
suspect out of that hmm oh well I think
I'm fine what okay there we go what am i
lights flashing again why is that a
thing that's happening why does that
keep happening who keeps doing that
no anyway I'm gonna get through these
men's and then everything's gonna be
fine
Oh to recap tomorrow big announcement
newton pacific standard time video on my
channel
big announcement you're gonna want to
see it it's pretty cool something we've
been working on for a while and it'll be
good
Thank You Arian marry paint Kirby Carey
be weirdos perfection Melinda Madden
Steven boost here alright we're almost
good on food oh we are good on food yes
we're going through okay so what I need
to do is a new build new build something
what are we doing now we're not doing
anything now Advanced Research Center
what happened with the Korean dog Lee we
gave the money we gave the money to the
Korean dog lady she got the money she
was unbelievably grateful really
incredibly grateful the sad part is we
would have had a video we had pictures I
posted pictures of it we would have had
a video of it but both my mom and my
uncle did not hit record on their phones
when they were capturing the video of it
both of them did not capture the moment
where I gave the money to her they
captured after the moment cuz they both
forgot it but we didn't take pictures
with her and she is incredibly grateful
like she was in tears and how grateful
she was because she kept saying like cuz
we gave six thousand five hundred
dollars to this lady who basically she
was rescuing dogs for the past like five
years now and she just has this small
farm like thing with dogs packed in
there to the brim just so many dogs and
they've all been neutered they've all
been fixed cuz it's nice that came in
and helped and fix them all so they
haven't had any like accidental puppies
or anything like that and they're just
it's just as incredible a that's doing
this completely selfishly so we were
able to give money to her and it like
she was just so unbelievable grateful to
have like this money she didn't expect
anyone to ever like do something like
this for her and you guys did that so
thank you guys for helping her in her
quest to save these dogs that is just
something like that she never ever
expected in her entire life and the fact
that she gets to like help out even more
dogs build a better facility for like
them you should have seen her bed her
bed was in this building this like
there's like converted storage building
in the very back it looked like a jail
cell where she slept and that's the kind
of condition that she lived in because
he just puts all of her money anything
that she could possibly make to saving
these dogs like she has nothing and
she's gonna put that money just to
building better facilities for these
dogs she's got over a hundred and fifty
dogs in this small compound tiny
compound they're all fed they're all
cared for they have their own space they
all get their own running time but she's
like a 24
our operation to make sure that these
dogs are well taken care of and so you
guys have done a lot and just thank you
for doing that
on a whim we decided to raise money for
this lady and we were I was able to
deliver it in person and he went to a
great cause so it's cool now my mom's
still in touch with her my mom has her
number and they just talk so and my mom
wants to help out more so that's really
cool
Thank You jasmine Barker thank you
what's it to you Thank You Ruby Ruby
Rose Dauntless her classic action Brett
lays leap take Wilmont erin murray paint
kirby Carrie be weirdos perfection
Melinda Madden Steven boots yeah oof ah
all right I need to do I said I was
gonna build a kitchen forever
mess hall okay
[Music]
sorry for the ears tomorrow right there
but I do
[Music]
whoa
okay what are we with a raw egg do we
have to cook raw egg we probably have to
cook raw egg so let's we probably have
to cook right let's not even do that one
we did it oh they're all clapping the
research oh wow well that's nice okay
let's get the electrolyzer going now
let's make sure that we have no you
should be fine okay we're gonna put an
electric grill there and we can fit one
more furniture in there we're gonna make
this place nice okay if this power go in
there remember we're gonna fix this
we're gonna fix this I was also told
that that um refrigerators are terrible
cuz if you're making more food than you
need it anyway then you're not doing it
right so let's get let's get whatever
hatch eggs are popping out of everywhere
let's get them in there and then
eventually we're gonna get we're gonna
get the wrangling and we're gonna get
the food really on with all these
hatches but for the time being we got to
do what we got to do and we're not gonna
get there until we get the Advanced
Research let's go for it let's go for
ranching cuz I like these sweet babies
shout out please mmm heart breaks
soldier I'll give you a shout-out but I
don't do shoutouts really Thank You
Emmett see thank you frost werewolf and
you ninja cookie Thank You Kyle Luke
Thank You Jennifer Rivera thank you bye
Oh sir Jasmine Barker what's it to you
thank you so much all right so there is
but both that let's get rid of this
thing
and then we can finally give Ethan a bed
he doesn't deserve it he still doesn't
deserve it I still firmly believe that
he does not deserve it but at least
he'll have one and because I'm nice and
I'm gracious like that I give it to him
but only because I'm nice and only
because I'm gracious I am nice and I'm
graces but he doesn't really deserve it
yeah well Ethan go into space
probably not I don't know if he deserves
that either so I'm gonna go big no on
that one did we good okay what do we got
can we make omelet
I like omelet hahaha call Neil axe sous
chef chefs okay who's gonna be a chef
ah-ha-ha-ha Ethan he found the chef well
if M is going to be a nicer chef a sous
chef if ever there was one
and as the Pels we could also make the
next one research be artistic expression
so that we could get it a little bit
nicer in here but for the time being
we'll just put some nasty laughs oh
that's it
that's what I would call not nice cuz
it's not symmetrical okay we're good to
that oh that's a real mass oh now that
is what I call a spicy and nice well
look at these and go look at them
cooking up a storm what a man what a
beautiful man cooking up all for
everybody to enjoy what their last one
man who could deny that Ethan knows what
he's doing around a spatula oh good the
bad thing what a beautiful man I can't
believe he's doing so good right now
love you you'll make your day I'm so
happy I could do that for you thank you
look at Ethan we knows his hands well he
knows his hands well oh yeah I does whoa
what the [ __ ] and race jetty don't mind
me just checking what the YouTube
exchange rate if you're wondering this
is supposed to be 200 Swedish kronor
which is roughly 11 dollars yes I'm an
economics thank you
Thank You Janet Elizabeth Sarah Sparrow
corrupted Rhapsody male yandere Alec are
Sam mashach broke into admin and thank
you everybody that's becoming a member
of the channel I want to do more members
stuff but again the notifications seem
to be completely broken at the moment so
that is just a work in progress but
finally a bed for Ethan so next research
we were doing artistic expression that's
right Pleasant chitchat welp there goes
Tyler just with picture picture perfect
right here I like this this is nice this
is nice that's as is hilarious
Thank You Timothy Boris I love all your
content and oxygen not included is one
of my favorite series that you do keep
being the lovable goofball that we all
enjoy I will do my best I will do my
very very damn best I'll do my Bant
a damn this then I'll do my best so
thank you for that be proud you were the
fastest sperm thank you I think
thank you I suppose thank you oh also
quick quick poll actual poll important
poll because YouTube's been broken
lately I did want to get an idea of like
have you been getting notifications
because it's been broken for a lot of
people yes or no and I need to get this
information back to YouTube because
there's obviously been something broken
and there have been something broken on
my own but I just want to know I'm
putting a poll in chat answer that one
that one please that one please anyone
anyone any sort of notification that you
usually would get that's this all I'm
asking right now oh look at the omelets
if I didn't know that omelets were gonna
be so good I would have been making
omelets ages ago hey that's so nice
we've got so much food now oh that's so
lovely what about what else could I make
mush fry no pickled mule I guess but
that just makes it a little less awful
fun of me I there's no harm to it so I
guess why not right I mean they're good
enough for now I'll raise the standard
of food later okay yes No Wow 37 per
second people have not been man that's
it's it'll and that makes sense that
lines up with what I was expecting like
some people are working and some people
are not not for community and members
stuff yeah I don't know why this is
bizarre and I suppose in you know it's
funny about that that's for the people
that are here the people that are here
are still like a third of you guys who
are here that made it in here and got a
notification for that I've answered that
so there's something going very wrong
about that no no why I'm not gonna raise
a stink about it at all like like a lot
of people like would you start clanging
the bell and be like yo dad it's dad but
I'm not gonna gonna do that oh no what
is that
AJ SW 1965 mark and love you can you
give a shout-out to me and my friends my
name is ang angel Angle Swanson and I
love your videos well your friends thank
you grinning Cheshire yeah where's
fröbel robos not here right now
they still haven't built this bed I
don't know
yeah it sucks
hopefully YouTube will sort this [ __ ]
out but they just haven't been able do
eventually eventually not now though
okay I'm gonna get the last of this easy
research and then we're gonna move on to
the bigger stuff
well showers that's right I was gonna
make him a nice shower
oh that's right okay I'm gonna get rid
of this because it's gonna be the
cleanliness supercomputer I don't like
that this isn't symmetrical I don't like
that oh I hate this I hate this I hate I
hate I hate I hate I hate I hate okay
you know what I hate it so much I'm
gonna move it over here that's how much
I hate it okay then we're gonna build a
nice shower a nice pooping room it's
gonna be nice and poopy damn nice pooper
and then we're gonna I'm still gonna
keep these as a backup we always know
we'll need backup I know we'll need a
backup but for now we're gonna make a
nice pooping room we're gonna have a
pump if I can get this pump down here
well they'd be well they'd even be able
to build this pump I mean this deep
water deep water yeah I'll put it there
for now just in case I still don't know
if they're gonna be able to get to it
but I'll put it there for now get the
pump there here's my pooping room get
the plumbing going for this right there
let's do that
there okay you know I I'm fully aware
that like this is the same level of
progress I've been making like every
time I play this as always I always get
to this point that I'm like I'll play it
again then I'm like I have to wait until
the next upgrade to come out but I'm not
gonna do that this time
I'm not gonna do that this time I'm
gonna get this and we're gonna do it
again we're gonna do it again and again
and again because I love this game and I
love this game we're gonna see some
progress it's gonna be great it's gonna
be great I promise you that it's gonna
be great we're gonna make it we're gonna
go far we're gonna get some [ __ ] done
we're gonna go far
but for now we allow brokers do oh
that's helpful not helpful what's
helpful right now okay break the youth
down put that there
mark is weijin I don't think that's the
technical term for it but okay Peggle
PAH
I am indeed beg wok I'm hungry I'm
hungry hungry hungry okay so that's out
of there so we're gonna make we need a
sink a proper sink
a nice proper sink I must space it out
so we can get another one in there but
I'm not gonna build it right away I'm
gonna build a nice lavatory
nope get that [ __ ] out of there I made
it the wrong way
oh I can't oh I can't cycle that one
that's dumb
that's dumb Oh like that that's dumb
that's what I call dumb okay and cold
showers for everybody apparently wasn't
even the point of rotating it if you
weren't gonna let me rotate it right
what was even the point of that [ __ ]
maybe the point of this that's stupid
Keanu it's gonna build a bunch anyway
I'll build them all up why wouldn't I
write by one night it's a dumb stupid
whatever okay this is all going out so
let's forget about
let's forget about this for now let's
get rid of that actually was cancelled
those because we're gonna build in there
there there there there and there
and what we can do is we can go straight
down from there - I bet they can't get
to this god damn it they can't can't
they maybe they can I don't know if
someone's gonna be brave enough to go
down there yeah whatever it doesn't
matter
correction left friction correction left
there we go hey it's coming together
pretty nicely we got so much food we've
got almost out the wazoo
we've got bristle berries we got meal
lice ah we're doing so good we're not so
good I've never done this good before
I've I've always put them into a
horrible horrible life they've always
had a horrible horrible existence from
then they regret with every fiber of
their being do they regret they regret
even being alive it was like why why
must life be pain why is life always
pain and then you know yeah that's
pretty good that's a bad think global
act local
okay this one's gonna chat on this was
just gonna get pooped dunked into its
mouth and it's gonna be so happy about
it the ones a freak right here this
one's gonna be like underneath this vent
there's gonna be [ __ ] water flowing out
of here Oh water shower runoff and it's
gonna be sitting in the bottom here just
in mouths a game ah more plays dribbling
down its chin it's gonna be awful it's
gonna be so disgusting we're gonna watch
what happens
could we hate it yeah all right way
we're gonna once this is done we need we
still needed this pump in there but I
don't know if they can make it and I
need to get power down there too
another thing that I'm gonna have to
reroute once we get it done but for now
connect everything dance [ __ ] whatever
don't matter connects everything [ __ ] it
yo Yolo man I write fellow kids Yolo and
such that image is horrifying
oh the image is the the little hatch
that it's no eyes just a big mouth just
hanging over having like a sewage pipe
directly into its gob what is that mess
with you you think that's ugly
do you think that's bad well I think
what maybe maybe you're bad maybe you're
wrong maybe you're wrong you ever think
about that you ever think about that
read my message can you make it tour to
Latvia
unfortunately no what about oxygen what
about oxygen we got plenty oxygen that's
so much oxygen we got you know we can
actually get another duplicate let's get
another duplicate in here mee-mah
you suck nema I'm not gonna get you you
suck why are we flashing why why are we
flashing stop we don't need the flashing
oh boy that's bad
AJ SW 1965 you're amazing if you can't
give me a shout-out in your next video
and still end your angles Watson sorry
if I'm asking too much you're just so
cool and funny and you always find a way
to make me laugh when I'm down and
depressed thank you for that I'm
shouting you out right now that's just
as much I can't chat you out in another
video but thank you big preach all
around Thank You Ruby Ruby Rose Thank
You Dale Anderson sans what's it to you
all nations
Dale Anderson tiene Driscoll never was
right corrupted rats to thee how much
did the charity stream raise yes the
charity stream raised $36,000 in three
hours the one that we just did impromptu
like a few days ago
$36,000 $36,000 in three hours I didn't
even tell anybody about it we didn't
even warn anybody about it was just like
instantaneous BAM suddenly a bunch of
charities so that was awesome
thank you guys so much for supporting
that means the world that he did oh yeah
we um can't build but can do everything
else that's fine bubbles I like bubbles
bubbles ain't cool
let's do bubbles all right bubbles do
you need a job can't build what are you
good at
I guess operating like having bubbles be
the general operator should be pretty
good right
does that bubble to be the operator
that's what that's what bubble seems to
be good at so why not freak where where
are you going Murray where you going
whatever why haven't I been going
maximum speed either
I've been going like suboptimal speed
here you guys are just making me do this
you just make bubble song baby bubbles
bubbles baby bubbles that's not a song
bubbles bubbles are you constantly
remind about your failure bubbles you
are you trying to sweep away your
nightmares that keep you awake at night
bubbles I thought I uprooted this yeah
whatever okay so we got this all set no
intake we still need intake they just
have not built anything I don't think
they can well they can no they can't can
they I'm confused
just build this you went down there
build it please I can lower the whole
water level by just digging by digging
out this area and hopefully they'll
lower it enough that they can actually
make a difference about it but until
they do I'm kind of stuck
yeah boo balls bubble butt returns
bubbles bubble doesn't have a bubble but
I don't think so anyway the volume is
breaking up I think that might be on
your end over there I don't think the
volume is breaking up at all because I
don't know anything okay good good there
we go there we go there we go hopefully
they're gonna be able oh hell yeah
you've got that muck root yeah wait wait
can you breathe in there you all right
Ethan you you guys okay are you pop to
your drums well no wonder you wouldn't
dare why'd you go in there there's
there's ten kilograms of oxygen in this
tiny little corner your ears popped
Ethan
all right anyway we got this up and
hopefully it'll be done in three two one
[Music]
whoo okay and now we got as soon as we
get water there oh yeah baby oh yeah oh
I can feel it I've got my ends and my
outs correct I'm good yes yes yes yes oh
yeah now the water's cold as balls but
that don't matter we got showers and we
got toilets better than having nothing I
would rather have a cold shower than
nothing at all
thank you war thunder Luna wolf
corrupted Rhapsody and Rule a valley
wizard saw star kid no palmer ruby ruby
rose thank you so much do i watch ruby
no i don't you internet okay everyone's
Idol right now we need to fix that
please don't walk through the muck let
me give him a way to not walk through
the muck here don't walk through no god
damn it of course god Wade you dirty
dirty [ __ ] oh my god you dirty bastard
oh my god are you so are you freaks God
stop wallowing in it stop wallowing in
the poopie why would you wallow in the
don't go get a shower go get a shower
you you dirty bastards why would you do
that why would you go waltzing through
it but I wouldn't you just go straight
to where you were gonna go
would you Waltons I just wanted to build
something where you could get what you
needed without going waltzing through
the [ __ ] that's around there and
there you are just pumping [ __ ] into
our food supply you need to wash your
hands no wonder you've dove oh great
great Murray great great that's great
thank you for that that's great no no
that's great it's great thank you it's
great great it's great I need to get
this out of here because that's not
supposed to be there and then I need to
get this out of here cuz that's not
supposed to be this is gonna be a
barracks and it's gonna be give a morale
bonus move use [ __ ] I gotta be
grateful anyway about this but I need to
make a piece of art here because then
this is gonna turn into a break room
gonna put some art air above hair so
they can be nice whatever it's fine
everything's good it's not that bad
thank you Christina yeast I met you
before the show in Denmark oh but I was
too scared to get a pic with you and I
regret it every day thank you for making
me laugh please play perception and this
was my last money well thank you so much
you don't need to give me any money
don't worry about that but thank you for
that and sorry you didn't get a picture
but hey you got a memory of it yeah
that's nice not the same but it's nice
so thank you I need to plug this in oh
thank you war thunder Thank You Luna
wolf thank you so much boink okay all
right okay unfortunately unfortunately
I'm all out of time but do not worry
because we're not done yet we're not
done with this I promise I'm gonna come
back right now YouTube is being real
[ __ ] with everything in terms of
notifications letting you guys know
about things and just generally overall
just being a giant [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
but we're gonna get through it we're
gonna fix everything I'm gonna leave
this here I want to do more streams like
this I want to do a longer stream so I
can actually have fun stream with you
guys for a long time we can do things Jo
joke around it
the memes you sassy sass holes so thank
you everybody so much for watching look
out for the announcement coming tomorrow
at noon pacific standard time it's going
to be really cool i think you guys are
gonna love it i'm really proud of how
far it's come
and i'm really proud of what it means
for the future and if you haven't been
getting notifications try to ring that
bell i guess if you haven't if you want
to see more of this definitely turn on
notifications so you know when i stream
because i don't have a regular schedule
even though i want to have a regular
schedule in doing things I'm just a
sporadic person so we'll see when that
comes around so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know anything
down the comments below and as always I
will see you oh god in the next video
bye bye bye guys bye bye bye bye